oh
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you um
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't want nobody
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
good morning
how are you
good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters at this time
okay sure you want to come forward
okay thank you
so
um
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right
all right your next witness
we call dr richard gilbert
dr gilbert
do you sell my square or a firm to
testify truthfully in this case in a
penalty of law
good morning sir
good morning dr gilbert good morning
would you please state your name for the
record
richard stephen gilbert
and what is your occupation
i am an orthopedic surgeon and i have a
sub specialty trending in surgery of the
hand and upper extremity
dr gilbert where do you work currently
i currently work in new york and long
island at northwell health
and you mentioned you have a specialty
can you tell us a little bit more about
what your specialty is
so after medical school i trained in
orthopedic surgery and i did an
orthopedic surgery residency
and for a year thereafter i did a hand
and upper extremity
surgery resin fellowship
and so my my practice for the past 22
years has been limited to surgery of the
hand wrist and elbow
and i think you may have
gotten ahead of me there but how long
have you been practicing
22 years okay
what percentage of your practice over
the past 22 years has involved surgery
approximately one-third of my practice
okay
and other than that one-third that
involves surgery what does the rest of
your practice entail
the rest of my practice entails
some academic work but mostly
seeing patients in the office seeing
them either pre or postoperatively a
large portion of hand surgeons
treat patients non-operatively
in terms of the surgeries that you do
can you describe for us um
the types of surgeries that you will
perform
so again i i limit my practice to hand
wrist and elbow i would say
approximately 75 or so of my practice is
limited to the hand itself
and this really varies from anything
from
conditions like carpal tunnel syndrome
to
tendonitis to injuries such as
amputations fractures
short lacerations etc
over the course of your 22 years of
practice
how many surgeries would you estimate
you performed
i performed about three to four hundred
surgeries a year so a rough estimate
would be approximately
uh 10 000
maybe a little less
where are you currently licensed
in new york
and how long have you been licensed in
new york
i've been licensed in new york since
1994.
so that would be uh 28 years
and do you have any certifications
yes
and can you tell us about those uh i am
board certified by the american board of
orthopedic surgery and i have a
certificate of added qualifications and
surgery of the hand from the american
society for surgery of the hand
when did you receive your board
certification
2002.
and can you describe for us what current
positions you hold
i am currently a an assistant professor
of orthopedic surgery at northwell
health
and i'm also the president-elect of the
new york society for surgery of the hand
in what professional organizations are
you a member
i'm a member of uh multiple orthopedic
organizations including the
american board of orthopedic surgery the
american association of orthopedic
surgery and
the american society for surgery with a
hand as well as the
new york society for surgery of the hand
have you published any articles in your
field yes i have
have you testified as an expert before
yes i have
can you ballpark for us how many times
uh certainly less than 10 over the past
22 years
your honor at this time we'd like to
offer dr gilbert as an expert in the
field of orthopedic surgery specializing
in the hand any objection no objection
ron so moved
so dr gilbert
what work were you asked to do in
connection with this case
so i was asked to review
medical records radiographs pictures
as well as
testimonies and depositions related to
mr deff's finger injury
okay
and
to your understanding
what is mr depp's explanation of how his
finger was injured
he describes that he was in australia
and his
right hand was over the side of a bar
when a
vodka bottle was thrown at his hand
injuring his right middle finger
and he describes that the vodka bottle
exploded
are you aware of other explanations for
that injury
uh there have been multiple other
explanations uh but i think the the one
that was was brought out was by miss
hurd who
believed that mr depp was holding a
landline and the anger was punching it
against the wall and this resulted in
his right middle finger injury
okay
based on your review of the
medical records
and other documents in connection with
mr depp's finger injury
how would you describe the nature of the
injury to mr depp's finger
well the nature of the injury was
he had what we described as a combinator
fracture of the distal phalanx meaning
there was a fracture of the tip of the
finger
and commodity meaning that there are
multiple pieces
so this is some type of
blunt force with a high mechanism of
injury he also sustained loss of the
tissue along what's called the ulnar
side of the finger towards the little
finger
and this
appeared
based upon my review of the pictures to
be some type of sharp laceration because
it represented a clean
edges of the wound
take a look at plaintiff's exhibit 60.
and pull up to go go to page three
and dr gilbert are you familiar with
this
document
yes
and what is it so these are two
radiographs x-rays of mr depp's fingers
finger his middle finger okay um
sorry just to stop you but uh your honor
may we publish this to the jury as a
demonstrative any objection
all right we'll identify it as 60 page
three and
publish the jury
and dr gilbert sorry sorry to cut you
off there can you can you just tell tell
the jury um
what we're looking at here in the second
right two x-rays of uh mr depp's right
middle finger after the injury and
towards the tip of the finger there's a
fracture
again what i described as a comedy dude
fracture meaning there are multiple
pieces at the tip there's also a
transverse component to the fracture
closer to the joint
in your view what types of mechanisms
can cause this sort of injury
so this is a
mechanism of injury that has high
velocity or force generally a crush type
injury
a simple fall would not result in a
common dude fracture such as as seen in
these x-rays
and we're using the term commented
fracture can we just define that quickly
for us so again common neutered and it's
not particular to a finger can
is a medical term for a fracture that
has multiple fragments
in your opinion could this injury have
been sustained in the manner mr depp
described i do believe so
and how might that work
how might a throne vodka bottle produce
an injury like this so vodka bottle
which is a hard object would have
crushed the tip of the finger resulting
in the accommodated fracture
and in addition as the vodka bottle
broke
the
glass would have
lacerated the finger resulting in the
soft tissue loss that was also seen with
this injury
what's your assessment of
the description of the cause of the
injury offered by ms hurd
i think that's highly unlikely
and
why is that
because one
in general when
an injury is caused by punching against
a
wall or a hard object
it is extremely rare to see an injury to
the tips of the fingers which is seen
with mr depp's injury generally you're
holding something with a fist
and that in general leads to injuries
most commonly of the knuckles here
or fractures of the metacarpals we call
these boxer fractures
second most common after those would be
injuries to these but as you can see if
you're holding something and make
hitting against something it is very
unlikely that
the tips of the fingers will be injured
in addition
just
taking into account the radiographs and
the pictures of the injury
i would not believe that a blunt force
solely a blunt force against a wall
would result in the soft tissue loss
what other injuries if any would you
expect to see
on mr depp's hand if the injury had
occurred as mr described
so
if you would have
if that were the cause of the injury you
would certainly that would be endorsely
directed so this is the doors on the
back of the hand
as opposed to the palmer side so if
you're punching against something you
would certainly expect an injury to the
nail bed and those are always seen in
those type of injuries if there is an
injury to the tip of the finger which
again i said is rare so you would see
either a loss of the nail or blood
underneath the nail called the sub-angle
hematoma
in your review of the medical records
did you see any sign of anything like
that no whatsoever
in your view is the injury
can you tell can you explain to us
exactly why you think the injury
is consistent with mr depp's description
well again
his hand he describes his hand being
held
over a marble bar which is a firm
something firm
unyielding and the bottle hit against
the finger
so basically the fingers crushed
resulting in again what i described as a
combinator fracture
and as mr depp described the bottle
exploded so
it's certainly reasonable that the the
glass that exploded as well
led to the soft tissue loss along the
ulnar aspect of his finger
okay
now did you observe the testimony of dr
richard moore
yes i did
and he testified about mr deb's finger
injury as well correct
did you agree with dr moore's testimony
uh certain parts of his testimony i did
yes
but not all of it
focusing on the parts that you well
first of all why don't you tell us what
you agree on
well he agreed in terms of his
interpretation of of the x-rays
saying that he had a comedy to fracture
and this was a
some type of high force injury okay
what did you disagree with
well i disagreed
with several things that he said he
first said that
he does not believe that the mechanism
of injury could be
as described by mr depp
holding the hand
on the side of a
marble
bar
because he said it was all a palmer
injury and
there was a palmer component to the
injury but i'm talking about the soft
tissue loss but there's also a dorsal
meaning the back of the finger
so the soft tissue loss was actually if
you
looked at the pictures which were shown
when dr moore
testified
the injury goes like this so it's it's
an angled or an oblique type injury
and there's no way that anybody could
determine whether or not it was a palmar
directive force meaning from the palm
side or dorsally directive force
but certainly either are plausible
okay
anything else come to mind that you
disagreed with
uh
well he also uh
described that
this was
definitive well he thought that this was
a pinching or what he described as an
avulsion type injury
and that's referring to the soft tissue
loss
um that's certainly possible but if you
look at the pictures that were shown uh
when he testified
the laceration looked fairly clean there
were clean edges it was not jagged and
generally when you have an avulsion or a
pinch type injury you see a very
irregular border to the skin
it's pinched off you can imagine as
opposed to something that's cleaner that
would be lacerated by let's just say a
piece of glass or a knife or whatever
and that's more consistent with the
pictures of mr depp's injury
and we're using the term soft tissue
loss and just to make sure we're on the
same page can you just tell very quickly
what you're referring to there right so
so he there were two
two components of this injury one the
fracture of the bone and two he had loss
of
the the soft tissues
so that the bone was exposed
so that amputated part that was found at
the bar
now you were saying that dr moore
testified that this was an avulsion
and
meaning a pinching injury right correct
why do you believe it's more likely that
it was a laceration
well again i i
in general a pinch-type injury results
in
one much more damage to the remaining
tissue but the remaining tissue is
usually very irregular the borders are
jagged
and that's not what was depicted in the
pictures
dr moore also testified that he thought
a vodka bottle might not have sufficient
force to cause the injury here
is that your understanding of his
testimony correct
what's your response to that
um i certainly believe that a
vodka bottle that was thrown from a
distance
against a hand that was resting on the
marble bore or is more than sufficient
force to result in this fracture and
soft tissue loss
now in in looking at the medical records
and the pictures of mr depp's hand
what was the condition of his nail
there was no injury to the nail
and other than what you've already told
us how does that factor into your
analysis if at all the fact that there
was no injury to the nail
well it it
makes it highly unlikely that the
mechanism of injury described by mis
heard
resulted in this injury because you
really
would would always see an injury to the
nail and or nail bed
do you have any opinion regarding the
direction of the injury
well
it's certainly
based upon the soft tissue loss it's an
angled injury or what we call a
medically an oblique injury because the
soft tissue loss is at an angle
he lost some of the tissue on the back
of the finger as well as the palm side
primarily along the palm side but other
than that
you can't make any assumptions
unless you saw a videotape of this
injury
nobody could tell you definitively what
the direction of the injury was
dr murr also commented on the absence of
fragments of broken glass in mr depp's
injury
do you remember that yes i do
and
how does the absence of glass fragments
factor into your analysis
it really doesn't um i've seen
hundreds if not
probably at least 500 or more glass
injuries and
i would say probably the majority you
don't see glass
in in these injuries
it is much more common to see
glass embedded in the wounds when you're
talking about very fine glass so if
to say a wine glass would explode or
something of that nature where you get
little tiny shards
but in general when you have thick glass
such as you see in a bottle or um or a
pane of glass you generally don't see
because they
break into bigger pieces and you
generally don't see the glass but um
you certainly can but it's not
surprising that you don't
can you definitively state how this
injury occurred
no i nobody can definitively state
okay
i have no no further questions all right
cross-examination
thank you your honor
good morning dr dylan good morning
now you're you're being paid a thousand
dollars an hour for your work on this
case correct correct
and you agree just to sum up how mr
moniz finished you agree that that the
finger injury could be could have been
caused by any number of things right
yes and you're not offering an expert
opinion on what you believe caused the
finger injury
correct
correct
and you're aware you you said a few
times misheard's account or misheard's
explanation
right you remember saying that yes
you're actually aware that that amber
has said she didn't doesn't know how he
lost his finger you're aware of that
right yes
so when you were just talking about miss
her's account or mr's explanation you're
where she's she's never actually given
an explanation for how she thinks he
lost his finger
correct
no
yeah
you're aware that miss heard testified
and this is from your deposition you're
aware that she testified she doesn't
know how he got his fingertip chopped
off you're aware of that right ask and
answer john
[Music]
no i'm not i reviewed the records
and in
one of the testimonies that i
depositions that i reviewed um it was
described that um
that
potentially it was lost
uh when he was punching against the wall
with the phone
and and on that
the last point there i think we agree
miss hertz testified in this trial and
previously that she saw him smash a
phone to smithereens a wall phone you'd
agree with that correct correct but she
doesn't know if that was what caused him
to lose his finger
you agree with that correct
i i
agree i cannot speak for her but yes
okay
matt approach yes sir
thank you
dr gilbert
you gave a deposition in this case on
march 17th correct correct you were
under oath in that deposition you swore
to tell the truth correct correct okay
if you could turn to page 61 please
you see there are four four pages per
page of paper
it's on page 16 of the document
okay
okay line nine
you're asked a question and then amber's
response to that question that's the
line nine can you read that please
answer
i do not know
i did not see his finger go off
question and dr gilbert are you aware
that amber did not see mr depp's finger
go off
answer i mean i'm aware that well i'm
aware from reading
i am from reading this i'm aware of the
mechanism that she claimed would cause
the finger injury question but have you
read anything so far that indicates she
doesn't know how the finger injury
happened answer so far from what i'm
reading here yes did i read that right
yes and
you've heard no testimony in this trial
from misheard that the finger injury was
definitively caused by the phone so that
she doesn't know correct correct and
you'd agree that the fingernail was
uninjured you said that right correct
and the nail bed was uninjured correct
correct
but the area under the fingernail in the
pulp of the finger that's where the
injury took place right
it was not isolated to the pulp no but
it didn't injure the fingernail that's
correct
and under mr depp's
alleged theory
amber threw a vodka bottle at him from
10 feet away or so right correct and you
testified you have no way to determine
the angle that the bottle was coming
from
correct but she threw it
on a downward trajectory correct she
didn't there's no allegation you've
never read anything that you somehow
underhanded it so it came up to his
finger right correct and there's no way
to tell as you testified what exact
direction it came from right correct and
the glass exploded but you've already
testified there was no glass in the
wound right
correct you haven't read any record of
that in any medical records correct
correct you also haven't read anything
about there being cuts on the rest of
his hand right correct and there was no
glass found anywhere on the rest of his
hand correct correct no bruising or
injury on any other part of his hand
other than the tip of his middle finger
correct
and somehow
under mr depp's theory that bottle hit
the bar
and his fingers but didn't damage the
fingernail while it amputated the area
under the nail
correct correct
and
your explanation of that
is that you believe
that his hand must have moved at some
point during the force of the injury
isn't that correct no i said it could
have but i i did not say that it did no
you you you believe that it did don't
you
i said that it likely did but i was not
there and i don't have videotape of the
injury so i can't determine that
definitively okay well
let's turn to page 25 of your deposition
please on page seven
sorry page page 25 and 26 so it's page
seven of the doc okay sorry if i was
unclear on that no problem
i'm there okay
line 18
question and to be clear
by quote sitting in that position you
mean hand down
palmer side down
answer that's what he claimed i mean
according to the history yes
question and would it matter if mr
depp's hand was palmer side down
answer not really because it really and
i discussed this it really just depends
upon the angle at which the injury
occurred and as well you can't determine
if his hand had moved at some point
during the force of the injury which i
believe it probably did
which i didn't get into in my note here
but
question and why do you believe that
have you read anything in any of the
materials to suggest that
answer
no
just that if it completely hit on the
back of the finger then he would have
had a nail bed injury which he did not
don't read that right correct that was
testimony you gave under oath a month or
two ago right correct
so even though you have never read
anything that suggests mr depp's hand
moved his hand moving is the only way
that you can fit your testimony
into what mr depp wants you to testify
to about how the injury occurred isn't
it no that's incorrect okay that's what
you testify to that if if his hand
hadn't moved that there would be a nail
bed injury correct that is incorrect
that's not what i testified
dr gilbert there's another explanation
for how mr depp somehow suffered an
injury that didn't injure his nail one
bit but injured underneath the nail and
that explanation is that it didn't
happen how mr depp says it did correct
i cannot make that assumption nor can
you
no further questions all right redirect
dr gilbert just very briefly
the absence of other cuts on mr depp's
hand
how do you factor that into your
analysis
you certainly can see an isolated finger
injury with any type of injury and i
would say
any other host of mechanisms of injuries
you'd more likely see other so again if
you're
i'm just using this as an example if
you're punching against a wall you would
more likely see multiple injuries to
multiple fingers it really just depends
upon how the bottle or
how the the
mechanism of the injury uh impacted the
hand at that point in time
this hurts counsel made a point of
emphasizing that there were no bruises
or other injuries on the hand right
correct
and
how does that fact uh affect your
analysis if at all
well it
it doesn't discount anything but it
certainly makes
uh other
potential
causes of injury more unlikely meaning
punching against the wall or getting the
hand slammed in a door or something like
that
and your
discussion of miss heard's explanation
of the
uh
alternative cause of the injury
was that based on anything other than
misheard statements
no
no further questions all right thank you
doctor you can have a seat in the
courtroom or you're free to go thank you
oh you can just leave it there that's
fine thank you sir thank you
all right
your next witness
plain defroster on it all right plenty
to rest the rebuttal case sorry
defended counter plane of rebuttal case
sure
all right rebuttal evidence
yes
mr murphy we call mr julian acker all
right
mr ackerd
do you solve a square or firmly testify
truthfully
good morning good morning can you please
state your name
julian ackert
and can you please describe your
educational background following high
school i have a bachelor of science in
computer science from the university of
virginia
what is your profession
i am a computer forensics investigator
where are you employed
i work for a company called eye
discovery solutions or ibs
and what is your title
i'm a managing director at that company
what services does ids perform
ids provides consulting expert testimony
forensic analysis data analysis
electronic data review and production
services all to the business and legal
community
what if any of those services performed
by ids have you performed i perform all
of those services
how many years of experience do you have
in computer forensics investigation i've
worked in the industry for 20 years
can you please describe that experience
to the jury
i have experience creating and
implementing data preservation and
collection strategies
uh doing data collections in a
forensically sound manner extracting
data from collections as well as
analysis and metadata analysis of the
evidence that i extract
you mentioned collecting data from
forensic collections
what material are you forensically
imaging
this would be any type of material that
stores digital evidence an iphone an
ipad a tablet a
laptop a cloud account your gmail
account anything that has digital
evidence
have you published in your areas of
expertise
yes i've published on data preservation
and collection and analysis strategies
have you ever given any trainings or
presentations to other individuals in
the e-discovery area
yes i have i do trainings and
presentations to lawyers through
continuous learning education
what if any professional certifications
do you have
i have a giac gcfe that's the gx
certified forensic examiner
certification
and what were the requirements of
obtaining that certification
to obtain that certification you need a
minimum number of hours in the field as
well as you need to pass a test with a
certain degree of uh
a certain percentage of passing
do you belong to any professional
organizations
i do i'm a member of a conference called
the sedona conference it's a conference
that
is a group of
legal professionals judges and
technologists and we discuss the
intersection of law and technology and
technology issues in the legal community
have you previously served as an expert
witness
yes i have
and when did you first serve as an
expert witness
i believe that would have been around
2009 was the first time i served
have you previously been qualified as an
expert witness in the field of computer
forensics
yes i have i've been qualified probably
a half dozen to a dozen times in both
federal and state court including this
court right here
and has a court ever declined to qualify
you as an expert witness
no they have not
your honor i offer julian acker is an
expert in the field of computer
forensics
no objection all right so could you just
spell your last name for me mr tracker
a-c-k-e-r-t thank you so much sir
mr acker what is forensic imaging
forensic imaging is the process of
capturing the data on a digital device
in a forensically sound manner
and how is a forensic copy created using
specialized software that's available to
forensic investigators we're able to
collect the data from devices and that
software may vary depending on the
device like a phone or a laptop
what type of information does a forensic
image collect
it's meant to really collect everything
on the device so for example on a laptop
it's going to collect your documents
your emails your photographs your
documents like excel spreadsheets pdf
files any applications that you ran
the the history of what you've opened or
looked at on the laptop as well as all
of the metadata for these different
types of electronically stored
information files
and does any other information accompany
that information that's collected
typically with a forensic image you're
also going to get log files log files
are files that help you validate the
forensic image and verify that it was a
forensically sound data collection and
how do log files enable you to do that
uh log files list information within the
files sometimes they're even embedded
within the images themselves but they
provide verification information that
allows you to authenticate the image and
the data on the image
what is the purpose of creating a
forensic image of devices or data
in order to extract and analyze data
forensically for the courts you need to
create a forensic image of the data
first and gather the forensic and gather
the data from the forensic image
and what if any specific types of data
are collected in that image and
extraction
it's going to be any type of data that
comes from the image whether you're
extracting photographs or documents or
spreadsheets or anything of that nature
do you recall mr newmeister mentioning
the term hashing yesterday
i do what is that
hashing is essentially the a digital
fingerprint of a file it's a evaluation
of the binary ones and zeros or how the
file is stored on a hard drive and it
examines the ones and zeros in a manner
that gives every file a digital
fingerprint essentially and identifies
the uniqueness of the file
and what if any applicability does
hashing have to the visual appearance of
data
hashing has nothing to do with the
visual appearance for example if i had a
word document that i
printed and then saved therefore i
haven't visually changed the word
document the metadata of that word
document indicating that i printed it
would be different and therefore that
word document would not hash to the
version that i
used before printing
can you give any examples of digital
photographs that visually appear the
same not hashing
i believe mr newmeister included three
of those in his demonstratives yesterday
three side-by-side photographs that uh
looked visually the same but did not
hash it made sense that they wouldn't
hash each of them had different file
sizes and a file size can change for a
photograph depending on what you do with
a photograph so for example maybe you
want to take that photograph and email
it to somebody and on your phone
you choose to use a small medium or
large or different size of the
photograph on your email when you send
that email with that photograph you've
changed the hash value because you've
changed the ones and zeros because
you've changed the size of the
photograph
and
what if anything do you recall from mr
newmeister's testimony regarding photos3
mr newmeister was concerned about a
particular metadata field exif metadata
which there's two types of metadata for
files there's the embedded metadata
which is what we're discussing here the
xf metadata and external metadata and mr
newmeister was concerned with embedded
metadata within the file that indicated
that the software version that the file
last ran through was photos
what is photos 3.0
photos is actually the software
application that's built into the apple
macintosh operating system for laptops
this is the application that launches by
default when you're on an apple computer
and use photos
what are the capabilities of photos 3.0
there's multiple capabilities for it you
can for example create an album with it
and put multiple photos within an album
you can
organize or sort your photos by date and
time taken or place you can also use
that to edit photos
you mentioned metadata earlier what is
that
metadata is information about a file for
example with a document it could be when
was the document created or last saved
or who saved it who was the author of
the document for photographs metadata
includes information that you've seen on
demonstratives before including
including when was the image taken what
kind of phone took the image what
software was originally used for that
image
any type of information inside the
photograph the exif data that you've
heard is metadata
did you form any opinions in response to
mr newmeister's testimony regarding
photos 3.0 appearing in a software exif
metadata field yes i did and what are
those uh my opinion is that
for each of the photos that he
identified for all but one in his
demonstrative i actually found the
equivalent original photo that did not
have photos in the xf metadata in other
words those are the photos that he was
indicated he would have expected to see
the ios or the phone software version on
those photos
how do you know it is an original
version of the photograph this is this
is a little bit dependent on the apple
ecosystem amber uses apple devices and
those devices by definition of how apple
works synchronize your information from
device to device so for example if you
take a photo on your phone you see that
same photo on your tablet or your ipad
or your icloud account or even your
macbook and that's all because of user
experience apple wants you to be able to
see and visually have the same
experience on all your devices so the
photo that was originally taken
traverses or gets synchronized to other
devices by design of apple and that
synchronization process does not affect
the metadata that we're talking about
here which is the embedded metadata
when you say that a version of ios
software was listed in the software exit
metadata field what does that mean
that means that the photo was not saved
using the photos application
and what if any data sets did you use to
come to that conclusion
i used all of the data sets that i
collected or were collected for amber
including mobile devices tablets laptops
etc
um michelle can you please pull up
defendants exhibit 1671
do you recognize this chart mr eckert
i do
what is it without without yet saying
what it the contents just generally what
is it uh this is a chart i created as
part of my report
your honor permission to publish
defendant 671 is a demonstrative
any objection no objection all right
it'll be published as a demonstrative
um mr acker can you please describe in
more detail what the information in this
chart is michelle if you could just stay
at the top for a quick second
a little further up
great thank you uh this chart represents
uh for each of the items in newmeister's
report which his demonstrative was based
on the page number of uh the item on his
report and the id the items that i found
on miss herd's devices that did not
indicate the software
metadata field showing
photos rather they indicated that they
were the original software metadata
field of ios
and do you see the second column titled
new meister report date captured
yes i do what does the information in
that column mean
this is the date time metadata of the
particular photo on new meister's report
so for example uh the first row 23 the
date time captured or the date captured
is december 16 2015.
the second row 24 you see that the date
time is may 21st 2016.
third row may 21st 2016
fourth row may 21st 2016.
you scroll to the next page please
michelle
please continue for the the items on
this page uh the top row of this page
the one that came from newmeister's
report page 30 shows december 16th 2016
and then finally 32 shows march 23 2013.
do you see
uh can you scroll back to the top please
michelle do you see the
um
follow at the top i'm sorry
the right hand column of this chart yes
i do and where it says device id and
file name
yes can you please explain what the
information in that column means for
each of the items identified from mr
newmeister's demonstrative
so these are the evidence ids and
evidence id is the id value i give to a
particular piece of data that i collect
for example a phone or a laptop and the
matching file name found on that
evidence id that indicated the original
version of this same photograph that
newmeister identified that did not show
photos in the software metadata and
rather showed the ios version in the
metadata
and what do the little
a's followed by numbers back up what
does that mean
those are evidence ids anything with an
a number is the evidence id of an actual
device collected anything that starts
with a backup and follows by another
number is an itunes backup
so what if any what
items in this right hand column
based on the
coding you have here are itunes backups
uh only the ones that start with the
word backup even the ones that start
with an a number are actually an itunes
or an ios backup in icloud so your phone
can actually be backed up to icloud and
those are coming from an ios backup and
icloud everything else is coming from an
actual physical device
um can you just take this down for a
second michelle and pull up 1675 please
defend in 1675.
and
do you recognize this chart mr eckert
yes i do without yet getting into the
contents can you please describe
generally what it is
this is a chart that i prepared as a
summary of my findings
um permission to publish defendant 1675
is a demonstrative your honor any
objection no objection all right 1675 we
publish this
can you please describe in more detail
what the three columns you can see in
this chart represent
sure this starts to give some detail
about the particular evidence id so for
example a001 was an iphone x of ambers
that was collected
a002 was an ipad of amber's collected uh
a 10 i'm sorry a11 12 and 13 slightly
down are three different laptops that
were collected for amber
and do you see the ids evidence number
column
yes i do
do you see the source type column yes i
do in the source details column yes i do
can you please describe what those
columns mean uh generally the idn's
evidence number is the evidence number
that we assigned to a particular piece
of evidence and the type and details
come from a description of that type of
evidence based upon the collection set
and michelle can you please do a side by
side of 1675 and 1671
thank you um
so mr actor can you please describe the
relationship between these two
demonstrative exhibits
certainly uh if you look at 1671 the one
on the left you can see in the fourth
column
the different evidence ids where i
identified the original versions of
those same pictures that mr newmeister
had uh specifically identified and the
sources of where they were identified so
if you look at the first one for example
the uh
the picture new meister referenced on
page 24
or i guess that's the second one there
are
equivalent versions or original versions
of those that do not show the software
excess metadata field of photos rather
it shows the original ios version on a01
which was amber heard's iphone x
a002 which is amber heard's ipad pro
scrolling on down through there you see
it on a011 which is amber heard's
laptop same with a0 12 and 13.
uh you can see this again with the next
row that's visible at the very top uh
newmeister identified a photograph on
page 30
taken on december 16 2015 and he was
concerned about the
exif metadata of that showing the
software version of photos the original
versions of those were found again on
a01 that's her iphone x a002 her ipad
and it's not surprising to me that i
found all these on all the devices
because that's how the apple ecosystem
works it replicates your pictures or
synchronizes your pictures across your
devices when you take them
um mr acker you can take this dumb shell
do you recall mr newmeister's testimony
regarding what he claims of exif
metadata modification
yes i do this is a completely
hypothetical scenario mr newmeister
never specified any pictures with
specificity that were had excess
metadata modification and it's a
hypothetical in my opinion
um mr acker did you form any overall
conclusions in this case
yes i did and what were those
the images that uh were created in this
case were included log files that
allowed me to validate and verify the
evidence collected i validated and
verified the log files of the
evidence for which i found mr
newmeister's original photos that he had
concerns about specifically the ones
that had ios and the software metadata
field
i validated that those came from devices
that had uh had been had log files that
were validated by me in other words they
came from original evidence files and in
in most instances they came from more
than one file
um
mr tracker the opinions you have
testified to testify to today made to a
reasonable degree of forensic certainty
yes they are
no further questions your honor all
right cross-examination sir
thank you your honor good morning sir
good morning
you've worked with opposing council's
law firm
approximately 20 times before
give or take yes
for more than a dozen years
those 20 probably would have spread out
been spread out over more than a dozen
years okay
as you sit here today
you cannot testify
that all of the photographs produced by
miss heard
are authentic originals correct
i can testify to the ones that mr
newmeister identified with specificity
right but there were thousands of
photographs
provided that mr newmeier didn't testify
about right
i have no opinions on any photographs
that the opposing expert has no opinions
on
my question to you though is
as you sit here today
can you testify that all the photographs
produced by miss heard are authentic
originals
as i sit here today i cannot open the
photographs that have not been presented
to me that are not authentic originals
you'll agree with me that in some
instances
misheard produced multiple versions of
the same photograph right
yes
yeah you just talked about it right yes
and you'll agree with me
that the xf data of some of the photos
produced by ms heard
reflect the use of a photo editing
application
no
no
i'll agree that they show the use of the
photos application which is a sorting
and editing application
okay so you what what you
were quibbling with is that it will both
sort and edit
that is correct okay
are you prepared to swear under oath
that each and every photograph provided
by ms heard
and entered into evidence in this court
is an authentic original
based on the metadata that i have
reviewed of the specific photographs i
have reviewed i can confirm that those
are authentic original photographs for
the ones that mr newmeister identified
identified photos that were authentic
originals no i'm asking a broader
question than that
there were multiple photographs that mr
provided that were entered into evidence
in this court
are you testifying
that those are each authentic originals
i have no uh testimony or opinion on
those because nobody's provided me
opinion that they're not
okay
mr gibson will you pull up
defendants exhibit 712
and defendant
713 next to one another
your honor these have already been
admitted and i ask that we publish it to
the jury okay they're admitted we can
publish
can you see this sir
yes i can
you'll agree with me that those are
different pictures
visually they look different to me yes
all right
we can take that down
mr gibson
can you
pull up plaintiff's exhibit
1308
this has not been admitted your honor
and and i propose to use it as a
demonstrative
any objection not as a demonstrative
your honor all right
be identified and publish the jury as a
democrat
any objection to entering it into
evidence
i would object it's cumulative your
honor actually no no no objection no
objection all right it's in evidence
then
1308 is in evidence
mr gibson can you blow up the time
date and file name
sir you just
agreed with me
that those two photos
are different photos
correct
i agree that they were visually
different yes right so they are two
visually different photos
that were created at the exact same
hour
the exact same minute
the exact same second
as each other correct
that's what the daytime metadata shows
yes
and the metadata shows something else
too
they have the exact same file name don't
they sir
yes but that's not embedded metadata
right
how would you have this jury decide
which one is real
i think you would need to look at the
software metadata field which i haven't
looked at i don't recall if i looked at
for this particular field but i think
that's what even mr newmeister said that
you need to look at the software
metadata field
but we have two
photographs entered into evidence in
this court
that have the same identifying
information but in your view
look visually different correct
i don't agree that they have the same
identifying information i don't see a
software metadata field here
the identifying information includes
them the hour minute and second they
were taken
this picture we're taking
i see that
no further questions all right and just
for the record since we already have 712
and 713 and evidence
as redacted now this will be seven
twelve and seven thirteen a so seven
twelve a and seven twelve thirteen a are
now in evidence just to keep the record
clean okay
all right redirect um mr acker you just
mentioned embedded metadata what is that
embedded metadata is metadata inside a
file oh i talked earlier about the date
printed of a word document that's
embedded into the file and that
traverses with the file wherever it goes
and based on all of the photo metadata
you have reviewed do you have any reason
to question the forensic authenticity of
any photos mr newmeister testified to
which you were responding to
you repeat that question yes based on
all of the photo metadata you have
reviewed based on the photos mr
newmeister testified to do you have any
reason to question the forensic
authenticity of those photos i do not
following your cross-examination mr
eckert have any of your opinions in this
matter changed they have not and is it
still your testimony that the opinions
you testified to do today are made with
a reasonable degree of forensic
certainty
yes no further questions all right thank
you sir you can have a seat in the
courtroom where you're free to go
all right did you want to approach just
for a moment
all right your next witness
your honor we would like to call dr don
hughes to the story dr hughes
thank you doctor just remind that you're
still under oath okay
thank you
and could you please just remind the
jury who you are again
sure i'm a clinical and forensic
psychologist i am board certified in
forensic psychology i am the
president-elect of the trauma division
of the american psychological
association
and i evaluated amber heard over six
visits for approximately 29 hours okay
and why are you here today
to offer a rebuttal testimony to shannon
curry's testimony of yesterday okay now
dr curry said you used improper methods
would you agree with that no i would not
why please explain
i as i testified to you all uh several
weeks ago i used a standard forensic
procedure that is well established in
our field it is a
multi-method multi-hypothesis driven
procedure where you're looking at a
variety of different details and tests
and external data to arrive at an
opinion and you're looking at the
consistency across that data
there are three sort of sets of of tests
that we use as forensic psychologists
and i think that's where it seems that
dr kari seems confused we have forensic
assessment instruments those are
instruments that are very neatly tied to
a legal criteria um those are most
notably done in a criminal court for
competency if someone has competencies
stand trial we have very clear measures
that can track that legal criteria
the next level are forensically relevant
instruments and those instruments are
not linked to a specific legal criteria
but they do have information that's
germane to that finding and that can be
an example of a risk assessment measure
and a malingering measure so the
malingering measure was that i utilized
was the mfast and that was the only
lingering measure in this case
the third category are clinical
assessment instruments and those are
instruments that are validated and well
researched and used in the clinical
realm as we understand people's
symptomatology and diagnostic
and functional capacities those are
things like
the mmpi the pai the caps the tsi
because they are clinically relevant and
they still give us very valuable
information to individuals who are
involved in a court case and the reason
that we do that and we use these
clinical measures is because the
majority of people that we see
are in a clinical realm they're not in a
courtroom um so they're well validated
in well-researched methods
what we also do is use a very different
types of tests within that category we
use some checklists some face valid
checklists we use some tests that are
those broadband personality inventories
we use structured clinical interviews
and then we look for the consistency
across those data points and when we use
different types of tests it gives us
information about the individual how
they go about these tests in these
different modalities
now
dr curry seemed to suggest that that
amber heard uh tested the most extreme
category in in all of these different
tests is that accurate
ejection compound
that is not accurate they were not on
the checklist i mean people sometimes do
they go all the time this happens to me
all the time frequently and that is not
how she endorsed these tests she
endorsed them in a very moderate way in
a very nuanced way describing her
symptoms
that i determined was accurate and
reliable
dr curry also suggested that
amber hurd was
tested very very high 98 percentile i
think i'm malingering and feigning
could you speak to that please sure so
i mean she said a lot of things so let's
go through those tests the first was the
pai and that's that other broadband
objection non-responsive
i think it's very responsive it's
sustainable okay could you tell the jury
about the pai test that dr kirk yes so
yes thank you so that's the broadband
measure that has validity scales built
into it that gives us indications about
how the individual goes about the test i
told you last time that there was no
evidence of malingering or exaggeration
or feigning on that test what dr curry
was talking about was this
tendency to put your best foot forward
to minimize faults on this pai
that scale was
right at the cusp and then there are two
other measures that we look at that to
say you know is this enough for an
elevation for me to consider that as a
serious response distortion of which dr
curry was saying and it was not
what was relevant on this test was there
were elevations on anxiety on effective
anxiety meaning anxiety tension worry
on traumatic stress
on
hyperactivity
and on affect of instability those were
the four scales that were elevated on
this test
the borderline scale was not elevated on
this test and this test objection your
honor
may we approach yes
so dr curry let's move to the tsi2 dr
curry testified about your findings on
that did you agree with her testimony
yesterday no again describe why explain
why um what dr curry went back to
which is this 98th percentile which i
told you in the manual all you have to
do is read the manual
it says specifically that we do not use
the percentile ranks for this test that
indicates to me that you know dr curry
does not know the psychometric
properties of this test and then she
then is therefore not qualified to
interpret it um that score the one
that's elevated but she's talking about
that percentile rank has a raw score
amber's raw score is a 10. the cutoff
score is a 15.
she's nowhere near that level of
exaggerated symptoms where i can't
further
look at that test
secondly there are three scales out of
about
maybe there's about 20 a little more on
the tsi that were elevated intrusive
experiences that's when thoughts and
memories of the trauma come into your
mind when you don't want them defensive
avoidance sort of behavioral ways that
we try to push out those memories and
not think about them and then relational
avoidance a way of having difficulty in
interpersonal relationships those are
all trauma-based symptoms and those were
elevated um on this test
thank you dr hughes uh the mfast dr
curry addressed that as well and had
criticisms for your interpretations do
you agree with that no please explain to
them so the mfast as i told you last
time is a measure of malingering it's
the only measure of malingering that was
done in this case dr curry did not
independently administer measure
malignant and their other ones that she
could have done to augment her
evaluation
and she kept saying something that mfast
is not for malingered ptsd
that's wrong on a couple levels
people who are going to maligner and
feign don't only feign one diagnosis
they sometimes talk about all different
symptoms that they have and they
exaggerate and they make themselves seem
much worse than they are so when you're
doing an evaluation you're giving them a
lingering measure to get a sense of how
this person is responding to this
evaluation now what you do is you take
those three tests that i talked to you
about the pai the tsi and the mfast all
with valid validity scales you have
greater confidence in your results and
that is in the literature and that's
literature that dr curry cited in her
report
that bolsters the methodology that i
used that in the study that had the pai
the mfast and the tsi in the title of
detecting feigned from bonafide ptsd
thank you now dr curry also talked about
the danger assessment scale and
suggested that you had inappropriately
interpreted that do you agree that's
also incorrect please describe for the
jury which i told you last time the
danger assessment scale has
statistically validated risk factors for
serious or lethal domestic violence
those risk factors exist whether we go
forward we're sitting with someone in an
acute setting and assessing them right
now or if we look backward and we look
retrospectively about what factors may
have been present in a case that
indicated severity
that instrument is used in what we call
there's called domestic fatality review
boards those are boards after somebody
has been killed a homicide has occurred
in a domestic situation they look at
these risk factors to see what was there
and what could be done
all right dr curry also criticized your
administration of the caps five do you
agree with her criticism i do not will
you please explain to the jury so the
the caps five as you all have heard
multiple times is a structured clinical
interview
in determining
ptsd according to dsm-5 criteria
on this measure amber heard scored in a
moderate range she did not over
exaggerate on this test she could have
said
no
mild moderate severe and extreme all of
hers were either twos or ones or zeros
not above that
so she's scoring in the moderate range
which still has functional impairments i
mean we don't want someone to be having
moderate ptsd but that's not an
exaggerated profile or exaggerated
response style of someone who's um
answering an instrument
and the last of these doctor curry
referred to was the pcl5
do you agree with her criticisms of your
administration and interpretation of
that no so the pcl5 is a checklist of
symptoms of ptsd it is
as she said it is a face validation
scenes it's very clear about how you can
endorse this but what the person has to
do is say how how disturbed am i by
these symptoms and when you have face
valid measures with these other measures
that have the built-in sort of ability
scales you're sort of controlling for
that response bias error you're
controlling for that
individual to sort of over exaggerate
but then what you do with that test
because this is you know we're not just
administering them like robots is you go
and you do a clinical assessment and
that's what i did i took what she wrote
what she endorsed on that test in
january of 2021 and i did a clinical
assessment of those symptoms to see if
they meet criteria for ptsd that is
something we do clinically and i do in
my office all the time and yes she did
me ptsd from that in january 2021.
thank you
now dr curry said you misinterpreted her
test results do you agree with that
yeah
i agree that i miss it i agree that i
interpreted that she misinterpreted them
okay
and please explain it yes so i am i said
that before i i you know my stance on
the mmpi and how she interpreted it is
i believe wrong and i think objection
your honor
that's the issue we just addressed
if you want to approach
now dr hughes dr curry also testified
that a victim of ptsd has to effectively
be prone and unable to function at all
would you agree with that
objection mistakes the evidence all
right she said they couldn't hike they
couldn't uh move they couldn't function
in any shape way shape or form
thank you
um no that is not correct that is often
actually a myth and misconception about
individuals who were struggling with
ptsd or trauma-based disorders and i'm
often called to answer that and speak to
that
you know people who are struggling with
trauma and ptsd are very
strong courageous resilient people even
though that they're struggling they get
up they have to go to work and drop
their kid off at school and go to the
market even though they're struggling
with these symptoms so i often talk
about it as a sort of walking around
with a 50 pound bag of flour on their
backs just sort of trying to get through
the day where sometimes that button is
going to press play and the trauma is
going to start activating in their head
and then they're going to be having to
think about it and have startle and have
physiological reactions until they can
find a way to hit that pause and shut it
off again so they still have you know
impairments in other ways but they go
about their lives they're not you know
totally debilitated if you have someone
in that high range the highest score is
an 80 on the caps miss heard had a 28 if
you have someone in the higher range we
have seen people who are you know
severely disabled because of it but
that's not the norm of people who have
um this moderate ptsd and did you find
functional impairment with amber yes i
did
now dr curry also said that
it is not within the scope of a
psychologist
to evaluate domestic violence do you
agree with that
of course i don't agree with that this
is what i do for a living day in day out
for 25 years
we are specifically trained to
understand the profound impact that
trauma has on people's lives that's what
we do in the trauma division of the
american psychological association we
disseminate that knowledge and domestic
violence is one of those profound
traumas domestic violence is part of um
state licensing boards that you can't
get licensed unless in some states
unless you take training on domestic
violence you can't renew your license
unless you get training on domestic
violence so people who have you know
specialized training in this area it is
you know holding upon them to accurately
assess for intimate partner violence and
sexual violence and it's in more
important to assess for this sort of
scientific understanding of what
domestic violence is so you have to
assess for the physical violence the
psychological violence the surveillance
the economic the emotional abuse and the
sexual violence that is not gratuitous
all right next question
okay
now dr curry suggested that you made a
determination just based on personal
opinion and just on checklists and a
couple of tests that you misinterpreted
would you agree with that
i vehemently disagree with that as i
stated to you over 29 hours and 12
psychological tests and reviewing a slew
of documents in this case most
importantly therapy records and
interviews collateral interviews with
therapists using all that data that is
what a a solid forensic methodological
exam looks like and then i made my
conclusions based on my clinical
education knowledge and training to come
up with a professional expert opinion
okay and just to remind you to make sure
we're reminded here you were qualified
in this court in this case as an expert
in forensic psychology and specifically
in domestic violence and in
the uh
no i just lost it uh
uh end in violence correct intimate end
in trauma correct objection your honor
mistakes the record
if you want to ask the question again
yes i probably should do that
um
you were qualified
i got to find my note
you were qualified as an expert in
forensic psychology with a specialty in
domestic violence and in trauma correct
correct okay and that was in this case
that's correct okay now do you still
hold the same opinions you did that you
gave the jury earlier
yes i do and do you still hold them
within a reasonable degree of
psychological probability and certainty
yes i do thank you all right
cross-examination yes rhonda can we
approach quickly
do
good morning dr hughes good morning mr
dennison
the last time you were here
i believed that you testified
that you had diagnosed
ms heard with ptsd
before you gave the gold standard
caps 5 test that's correct right and
that diagnosis
is actually reflected in the first of
the
disclosures you put forward in this case
i believe the first disclosure was
february 2021 and at that point i had
done
11 psychological tests that's correct
right
and
your disclosure reads ms heard's
responses on the pcl5
support a dsm-5 diagnosis
of
post-traumatic stress disorder
with an
ideology ideology of intimate partner
violence she experienced my former
partner remember writing that that's
correct
okay
you just testified
that you need to read the manual
right yes okay
can we put up 1311 as a demonstrative
any objection to 1311 it is your
thomas
thank you
i
don't see this in my document either
they're getting the right one up yup
let's use 13 12. 13 12
okay
and that
any objection to that demonstrative
okay 13-12 can be published the jury
dr hughes um
do you recognize what the national
center for ptsd is
what it is yes i do
and they publish um
the ptsd checklist for dsm-5 that's
correct that what we've been calling the
pcl5 correct
all right
and do you
uh are you familiar with the document
that's uh on your screen yes
what is it
uh it's
the instruction manual to how to
administer the pcl5
okay
i'd like to move for the admission of
any objections of 1312 coming into
evidence all right 13 12 in evidence
can we go to the second page
can we blow up
the second paragraph
on the right
the pcl5 should not be used as a
standalone diagnostic tool
considering when considering a diagnosis
the clinician will still need to use
to use clinical interviewing skills and
a recommended structured interview
e.g
the caps five
to determine a diagnosis correct that's
what the that's what the manual says
right in this manual also says that this
is a screening instrument so when you do
the clinical interviewing you absolutely
can determine diagnosis
is yes the manual says you you
still need pc clinical interviewing
skills which i use
let me finish my question
the pcl5 should not be used as a
standalone diagnostic tool
and they recommend using the caps 5 to
determine a diagnosis correct
it does say that yes yeah and you made
your diagnosis before
you did the caps 5.
i made my diagnosis doing clinical
interviewing and 11 other psychological
tests that supported diagnosis of ptsd
and symptomatology consistent with ptsd
okay um
you said that we should read the manual
would you also agree with me that we
need to read the directions
on these tests
sure
okay
tom can you pull up
1309 as a demonstrative
yes sir
thank you
any objection of 1309 as a demonstration
may we approach okay
you know nine and publish the jury is
democracy
doctor do you
recognize
the
uh demonstrative that's in front of you
yes but i didn't put the red lines on
that no i did yes i know okay
um
so
this
what do you recognize this ass
i recognize that we previously discussed
this and i told you that i oriented miss
her to a different time frame because
she was already out of the relationship
okay um maybe we should back it up a
little this is the cts 2
that you administered as part of this
battery of tests that you
indicate you ought uh you did in
relationship to your diagnosis right
this is the conflict tactic scale too
sorry and you'll agree with me
that this test specifically asks
in front of every single question
how often did this happen in the past
year
correct and i oriented the individual to
not limit herself to the last year to
get an accurate assessment of the
violence and abuse that she experienced
in the relationship objection you're
going to move to strike all right i'll
move strike the last part of the answer
i mean strike the last part of the
answer thank you
next question yeah and you know that at
the time
that you gave this test to miss heard
she had been away from mr depp
for far longer than a year correct which
is why i oriented her to a different
time frame in answering the question
doctor yes or no of course okay you knew
she was gone for more than a year of
course all right
let's look at another one of these
[Music]
you talked about the danger assessment
test that's correct all right
thirteen plaintiffs thirteen ten
thank you
any objection to the thirteen ten uh
demonstrative okay
you publish the jury
dr hughes
uh
this is a blank form but this is the
dangerous assessment test that you
also gave to miss her correct
i didn't give it to where i filled it
out based on the data that was provided
to me oh so you answer the questions and
then you filtered it
it was somewhat collaborative
okay
can we
blow up the second full paragraph
it says using the calendar please mark
the approximate dates during the past
year when you were abused by your
partner or ex-partner
you didn't use any calendar did you
i did not use a calendar because she was
already out of the relationship as i
said these are static risk factor so
they don't change so i oriented to the
time of the
relationship
ma'am it's fair to say that ever this
examine
examination that you gave
specifically indicates that it's that
you were supposed to look over the past
year
and you
that's the one no that's one
administration people use this
instrument for if you're in an acute
situation in a relationship trying to
get a better assessment of the current
behaviors we can use it retrospectively
like i just stated and in homicides and
looking back about what are the serious
risk factors that were in this
relationship i didn't ask you about
anything other than don't the
instructions
limit this test to the previous year
you can give this test not only on the
previous asking you about the
instructions but i'm telling you how the
test is administered in clinical
practice and forensic practice and
opposing counsel can come up and ask
questions about it i'm asking you about
the instructions and the instructions
say
look over the past year
yeah on this yes that it says that and
you had actual knowledge when you gave
the test
that mr depp was gone way more than a
year before this test that is correct
right
all right let's look at more
instructions
can we look at 1247 which is already in
evidence
dr hughes
you recognize this one too right yes all
right this is the
what everybody calls the caps five
correct can we go the first page
let's blow up the instructions
standard administration and scoring of
the caps 5 are essential for producing
reliable and valid scores
and diagnostic decisions
correct correct
and you know you have to do this in a
standardized way because it is the first
instruction correct correct
can we go to the next to the
next
page one more oh wait
that's good
this is a page on scoring and we talked
about this last time yes you score these
tests
by
frequency and intensity correct
and you'll remember that
in every single instance that you were
asked to fill in the blank
about frequency
you failed to do so correct that's not
correct oh
you you filled in
any blank on this form with respect to
frequency
i filled in the frequency on the side of
the caps where i am actually scoring the
caps
no i asked you whether you filled in a
single blank on this form with respect
to frequency
is the answer to that yes or no i don't
know what you mean a single blank all
right let's let's page
down
let's keep going all right let's
we'll stay at this page for a second
um this is the very first
box you're asked to fill in
as to
i think a fairly fundamental question
right what happened
we talked about this before mr dennis
and i had 88 pages of notes of what
happened it would have been redundant to
put it there you know that you are
obligated to produce this test in a way
that other people can meaningly review
them
yes the people in this case who are
meaningfully reviewing them have my 88
pages of notes right but you chose
to put absolutely
nothing in the box the standardized box
that said what happened
you don't have to put it in the box if
you have it somewhere else it's not this
is not a standardized test if it's on a
research instrument that is used for
research if you're using it for a
clinical diagnostic purpose no you don't
if you have that data elsewhere okay
let's go another page or so
all right
let's go another one
all right let's look at item
4b4
and i asked you whether you filled in
the blank
about frequency
and there's a blank in many of these
items
that asks
number of times
you didn't fill a single one of them
into you
right because i filled them on the right
side of the instrument where i am
scoring it
and that is the way that you believe
that you followed the instructions
of a standardized test yes correct no
further questions
all right redirect
very briefly
static risk factor what did you mean by
that
static risk factors or risk factors that
don't change it's maybe um if you smoke
cigarettes you may have a risk of lung
cancer right that's a factor that
doesn't change you can look forward if
someone's smoking you can look fast if
someone's smoking so these
lethality risk factors are present
whether you're evaluating them in the
last year
or five years ago
and when you're trying to assess for
trauma related to the interpersonal
violence that we discussed
why is it important to get a time frame
in which the relationship was
in existence
well you want to see the amount of
trauma that the person experience the
longer that they're in a relationship
you have more successive trauma and one
of the things that we know from the
research is more trauma is not better so
the more successive traumas that you
have the greater likelihood that
somebody's going to have psychological
consequences and symptomatology as a
result and therefore you need to get it
within the relationship objection
leading
and so how does that
relate to needing to get the time frame
in the relationship well you need to
understand the
when you're under when you're trying to
evaluate the impact of something you
won't have to understand what happened
to the person and that's sort of the
core and the basis of of trauma-informed
care and a trauma diagnosis you have to
understand you know the traumatic event
and how it transpired and how it played
out for that individual so that you can
better assess for the symptomatology
that's falling from it
you said you had 88 pages of notes what
were in your 88 and without going into
the specifics can you just describe what
was included in the 88 pages of notes
um in the 88 pages were um
many of the documented incidents of
intimate fraud objection your honor
she's just describing it that came up he
said you didn't fill those in the boxes
she said it was in my 88 pages i'm just
saying what was in your 88 pages i'm not
asking her to give each of the specific
events she can describe the summary of
it
can we come up
this
what is the difference between
clinical scoring and clinical evaluation
and research evaluation with respect to
the caps five and the other tests
and
compounds sustained
you're on
when it's compounded because it might be
confusing to the jury
sustain next question okay
can you explain to the jury what the
difference is between clinical scoring
and evaluation on a test and research
protection your honor compound
overruled gun sure so the the pcl
and the caps fiber are frequently used
in research and when they're used in
research that means the document stands
alone they don't have 88 pages of notes
to help understand the background of the
trauma and what the person has
experienced and why those boxes may be
relevant in research is because you know
back in the day when i was a research
assistant i had to input that into the
computer and then they would maybe look
at some of that data for the research
study so that becomes very important in
research
all right thank you i have no further
questions all right thank you dr hughes
you could have seen the courtroom where
you're free to go okay thank you very
much all right ladies and gentlemen
let's go ahead and take our afternoon
recess i mean sorry our morning recess
i'll just take our 15-minute recess do
not discuss the case with anybody and
don't do any outside research okay
so
all right why don't we just come back at
1105 then
yes yes sir
so
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
maybe seated all right your next witness
your honor defendant calls amber hurt
all right i heard if you come to the
stand please
yes ma'am
water
thank you ma'am just a reminder you're
still under oath okay of course your
honor thank you thank you all right your
question
amber just to orient you and the jury at
this time we are in the rebuttal to your
counter claim against mr depp so i'm
going to confine my questions to that
okay all right
how have you suffered publicly as a
result of the dep waldman statements
objection speculation
overrule
i am harassed
humiliated
threatened
every single day
even just walking into this courtroom
sitting here
in front of the world
having the worst parts of my life
things i've lived through
used to humiliate me
people want to kill me and they tell me
so
every day
people want to put my baby in the
microwave
and they tell me that
johnny
threatened
promised
promised me
that if i ever left him he'd make me
think of him
every single day
that i lived objection your honor
non-responsive all right i'll sustain
the objection as to that if you want to
ask the question
amber
how did mr depp's
statements and threats to you that you
were discussing
how do those continue to manifest
themselves today
in the harassment and the humiliation
the campaign against me that's echoed
every single day
on social media and now
in front of cameras in this room
every single day i have to relive the
trauma
my hands shake i wake up screaming i
i have to live with the trauma and the
damage done to me
my friends have to live with a set of
unspoken rules about how to not scare me
objection hearsay
yes sir unspoken rules
about how to not touch me
not to surprise me
my intimate partners
have rules about
how they can deal with me how they can
touch me
i have rules for doctors medical
professionals i see gynecologists i see
i live my life
with these sets of rules that i have to
follow my friends have to follow for me
not to have a panic attack or a
triggering event
where i relive the trauma even if i'm
training to do my movie for instance i'm
training for aquaman
a combat scene and a trigger happens
i have a meltdown
and have to deal with that the the crew
i work with have to deal with that
because of the damage i walk around with
every single day
from what i've lived through
from what i've survived i'm not sitting
in this courtroom snickering
i'm not sitting in this courtroom
laughing smiling making snide jokes i'm
not
this is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being
to go through
and perhaps it's easy to forget that but
i'm a human being
and even though johnny promised that i
deserve this and promise you do this i
don't deserve this
i want to move on
the statements
the attacks on me the campaign
that
that johnny has elicited millions of
people
to do on his behalf when he himself
foundation torture me speculation
i'll sustain the objection next question
amber
how the dep waldman statements impacted
your ability
to do charitable work
you know
i would
the only reason that
people like dr kirby can sit up here on
the stand and say i'm high functioning
and i do things like have hobbies
and have interest
objections responsive
your honor mr depp gave long-winded
responses
it's because i found a solution to that
pain
i woke up every morning
with panic attacks and
trauma until i realized i could do
something with it
so to answer your question ben it's i
i was able to turn the things that i've
lived through my pain my life
experiences into work into action into
providing a voice for other people
i'm not a saint i'm not trying to
present myself as one as you all know
but i
selfishly found
relief
in being able to use what i've lived
through
to advocate for others
to bring light to these issues to give a
voice to people who don't have the voice
and the platform that i have
and while i would not wish this
situation on my worst enemy
if it gives a voice to someone who
doesn't have it
but i now as i stand here today can't
have a career
i can't even have people associate with
me because of the threats and the
attacks that they have to endure fashion
will be responsive and it can't hurt you
will sustain the objection
[Music]
amber other than the threats that you've
described what other
threats have you endured since the debt
waldman statements were made
i receive
hundreds
of death threats
regularly if not daily
thousands
since this trial has started people
mocking
mocking
my testimony about being assaulted
making fun of my objection relevance
non-responsiveness
you can continue
it's been
agonizing
agonizing
painful
and most humiliating
thing i've ever had to go through
oh no one ever has to go through
something like this
oh
i just want johnny to leave me alone i
just want him to leave me alone
i've said that
for years now and i thought he would
after two non-responsive
right i'll sustain objection next
question
what do you hope to reclaim
after this is over
protecting the secret that i
did for as long as i did
has taken enough of my voice
johnny has taken enough of my voice
i have the right
to tell my story i have the right to say
what happened to me i feel right to my
voice and my name
he took it long enough
i have a right as an american
to talk about what happened to me to own
my story and my truth
i have that right
i hope to get my voice back
it's all i want
and i've said that from day one
thank you amber i don't have anything
else all right cross-examination
actually your honor may we approach yes
miss her you just testified that this
case has been very hard for you so let's
talk about that and why
all right
your lies have been exposed to the world
multiple times right
i've been lied about anything i've been
here to say
you sat here and told this jury that the
events in hicksville started with mr
depp getting really upset about a woman
leaning on you is that correct
yes that's effectively what happened
yeah you testified that he actually
grabbed that woman's wrist and twisted
it right
and told her
that he could effectively break her
wrist by saying he knew how many pounds
of pressure asking her how many pounds
of pressure it took to break the human
wrist but your own witness your former
best friend rocky pennington she didn't
corroborate that did she
i'm not quite sure what part of that
night she saw there were a lot of people
there
she didn't testify that mr deb grabbed
anyone's wrist in hicksville again i
don't know what rocky saw there were a
lot of people there that night you
testified that once you brought mr depp
back to your trailer he trashed it
correct
that is correct
and the manager of the hicksville
trailer park was furious that johnny had
wrecked the whole thing do you remember
that testimony that's correct well we
heard from that manager of the
hicksville trailer park morgan knight on
monday didn't we
i'm not quite sure who that guy was or
if he had any involvement in this i know
a lot of people have come out of the
woodwork to be in involved
so you're accusing mr knight of
testifying
and committing perjury i'm not accusing
anyone i just don't recognize that man
you heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was upset with mr depp
spending time away from him isn't that
correct
how would he know he wasn't there
you heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was yelling at mr dub
again
i've heard a lot of people say a lot of
things to be involved in the johnny depp
show but
he wasn't there
he doesn't know and he certainly doesn't
know what happened behind closed doors
like most people so you're calling mr
knight a liar
i am saying he wasn't there and what he
testified to doesn't match what i know
happened
but i don't fault him he wasn't there so
how would he know
he testified he was there misheard did
you hear that that's his testimony yes
so you're calling him a liar
i'm just saying he wasn't there
you heard mr knight testify that the
trailer wasn't trashed and that's why
you're calling him a liar
he testified that a light fixture was
broken similar to the way that yeah
the only thing that was broken in the
trailer according to mr knight was a
light fixture yes or no i realized that
he summed it up by saying a light
fixture was broken just wait his
security guard summed up him trashing my
closet as being ready i'm going to move
to strike everything after he summed it
up that it was a light fixture
as non-responsive she answered the
question
the security guard testimony i'll allow
it go ahead
mr knight also testified that he charged
mr deb only 62 dollars for the damage
light fixture you heard that correct i
did
in hicksville you were the only one that
was jealous and mr deaf was spending
time from other people isn't that
correct mister that is incorrect in
hicksville you were the one who was
upset that mr depp wasn't giving you
enough attention
incorrect again
it's heard you told this jury that you
had no idea the press was going to be at
the courthouse when you got your tro on
may 27 2016 do you remember that
testimony
uh i said i did not have anything to do
with it yes
no
my question again
you told this jury
that you had no idea that the press was
going to be outside after you got the ex
party tro on may 27th 2016. do you
remember that testimony i apologize i
must have misunderstood miss vasquez um
i actually had no idea whether they were
going to be there or not when i walked
into the courtroom that day it was
completely quiet still empty
even though i had given johnny's team
notice that i was fighting for the
trophy
to move to strength
and your honor i would also ask that you
instruct the witness to please stop
talking once i lodge an objection your
honor she's trying to answer the
question as best she can miss vasquez is
misrepresenting to her what she
testified too well i i'll start the last
part is non-responsive just if you guys
answer the questions asked okay thank
you miss her
in fact you testified that you were
quote shocked when you saw press when
you were leaving the courthouse yes yes
you weren't shocked at all though were
you
uh incorrect it was you knew the press
would be at the courthouse right miss
heard
no
well you did bring your publicist to the
courthouse with you on may 27 2016
didn't you i sure did i'm a public
figure i brought my publicist in case it
blew up in case you actually had alerted
tmc that you would be filing a tiara
against mr depp that very day didn't you
no i didn't one day you didn't bother to
wear makeup to cover up the mark on your
face i did not call tmz or any other
news source or paparazzi source no one
i never did testimony from former tmz
employee morgan tremaine yesterday
correct did i hear his testimony yes yes
i was here yes and you heard mr
tremaine's testimony that he knew to
dispatch the paparazzi to the courthouse
on may 27th right i heard him say that
he knew that yes yeah and that he
dispatched paparazzi to the courthouse
to capture a picture of an alleged
bruise on the right side of your face do
you remember him saying that i remember
him saying that
that information must have come from
your team right miss heard absolutely
not
why would i want that what actual
survivor of domestic violence wants that
now the video of mr depp beating up some
kitchen cabinets you admit that you took
that video correct
yes i did
and you acknowledged that the video was
released online the day before you were
deposed in connection with your divorce
from mr depp in august of 2016. right i
believe it was yes but you testified
that you had absolutely nothing to do
with the video's release right
absolutely not
and you testified that you learned about
it when you landed after flying into la
do you remember that testimony upon
touchdown is when i was alerted to the
videos you heard mr tremaine testify
that this about this video as well
yesterday didn't you yes i did and you
heard mr tremaine testify that tmz
received the cabinet video the same day
you landed at lax yes
i don't know if that i i don't know if
that's what his testimony was i'm sorry
you heard mr tumain testify that the
cabinet video was posted
15 minutes after tmz received it yes
that's what i heard him say and that
this could only have been possible if
the video was received directly from the
source yes i heard him say that i don't
know if that's true or if that's
possible because it didn't come from me
i was flying tremaine so
i know that's incorrect is what i mean
to say
another liar on the stand i just know
that that's incorrect right and you
heard mr tremaine testify that tmz owns
the copyright to the cabinet video right
that's news to me the cabinet video you
filmed of your then husband yes
the copyright ownership of that is news
to me i learned that yesterday it's the
cabinet video that you captured of your
then husband yes that is correct i did
capture that video and yes
my husband the same cabinet video that
was released the night before you were
deposed in your divorce yes that's
correct you must have also heard mr
tumain testify that the version of the
cabinet video that tmz received was
incomplete compared to the video the
jury saw in this trial did you hear that
the video that the jury that you have
seen is complete
right but the one tmz got the day before
your deposition in the divorce was
incomplete i don't know i haven't seen
it he testified that at the beginning
portion of the video where you set up
the camera that wasn't included in the
video that tmc received i don't know
what video tmz i'm talking about mr
tremaine's testimony was heard let's
just focus
his testimony no i'm asking you if you
recall hearing him say those words to
this jury
i heard his testimony we all did and he
testified at the end of the video where
you can see be seen smirking
i know you testified earlier that you
haven't been smirking in this trial but
you sure were caught on camera smirking
in that video i disagree with that
was also not included in the tmz video
everyone can watch that video and you
can determine whether you think it's
funny to me or not that's because the
video came from you right miss heard
no it did not you had a video portion
you edited out the portions that made
you look bad before sending it to tmc
you were very wrong about that so that i
wanted to leave information i could have
done it in a more effective way a lot
sooner and a lot more because i was
living in the mountain of this evidence
if i wanted to leak it i could have done
a lot more with it
i thought you testified earlier in this
trial that you didn't know how to leak
things i don't
right
you edited that video before you gave it
to tmz so that only mr depp would look
bad yes that's absurd
right in the middle of your divorce
proceedings
again you're very wrong
i'd like to show you
a picture from that's already admitted
into evidence it's defendants exhibit
799.
this is you at the courthouse on may 27
2016 when you got your domestic violence
restraining order against mr depp right
it is and next to you is a woman named
jody gottlieb right yes jody gottlieb is
your publicist and dear friend
now i'd like to show you what's been
marked as plaintiff's exhibit 1316.
this is a picture of you and your friend
rocky pennington right that is correct
your honor i'd like to move to admit
this photograph any objection to 1316.
no your honor all right 1316 in evidence
you can publish the journey
this is a picture of you on may 28 2016
right ms hurd i don't know when this was
taken
this is the day after you obtained the
domestic violence restraining order
against mr death right
i have no idea when this image was taken
i did not take it there's no bruise on
your face in this picture is there again
i don't know when this was taken and
also i'm outside i was obviously wearing
makeup i have no idea when this was
taken so i have no idea if i can speak
for special recollections let's refresh
your recollection about when this
picture was taken um can we please pull
up plaintiff's exhibit 1315 just for the
witness
this is an article dated may 30th 2016
right miss heard
that's what it says yes
and this article contains the same
photograph of you miss pennington we
were just looking at yes
yes i see that and the article is
entitled amber heard smiles as she puts
arm around friend one day after getting
restraining order against johnny depp
is that what the title says
i know that's what the title says yes
your honor i'm going to move to admit
and publish the article with everything
but the headline and date and the photo
redacted
objection your honor that's inconsistent
from the way you treated all of these
i'll sustain the objection all right
next question
let's take a look at picture plaintiff's
exhibit 1317.
this is also a picture of you and miss
pennington on may 28 2016 isn't it i
don't know when this photo was taken but
it looks like the same outing as a
picture prior your honor i'm going to
move to admit and publish plaintiff's
exhibit 1317 any objection no you're not
all right 1317 in evidence you can
publish
there's no bruise on your face in this
picture either right
i disagree uh if it is
taken when you represent it was taken
then obviously there's a bruise on my
face it's covered by makeup as per usual
let's zoom out of that picture for a
moment please thanks tom
that's josh drew in this picture right
yes that's correct miss pennington that
is correct
in there too
mr pennington submitted a sworn
statement on your behalf in support of
your domestic violence restraining order
didn't she
i believe she did yes mr drew also
submitted a statement in support of your
domestic violence restraining order
i believe they both did yes
yes sir i'd like to show you defendants
exhibit 512 which is already in evidence
you've seen this photograph before right
i have
on the second day of your direct
testimony you testified that this was
taken in the downstairs of the main
apartment on december 15 2015. do you
recall that testimony
yes i believe so
so it's your testimony that defendants
exhibit 512 reflects damage to penthouse
5 that occurred during the december 15
2015 incident yes
i'm not quite sure
from what incident this is when i see
this photo in a in a vacuum without
context
let's give you that context
can we please thanks i could have day 16
trial testimony
approach all right
could you please turn first to page
four five eight five
sorry one second
specifically on starting on line 16
where it says let's talk about december
15th 2015.
you said four five eight four i'm on
four four eight five sorry you said four
five eight five four five eight five are
done line sixteen
line 16 where it says let's talk about
december 15 2015. do you see that
yes
and then do you see that your testimony
about december 15 2015 follows
let's see it's just the first line or
two
yes okay now i'd like you to turn to
page four six zero three
starting at line twelve
four six zero three
starting at line 12 and going on to page
4604 line four
okay
and do you see that you testify that
defendants exhibit 512 which is on the
screen yes is a picture of the
downstairs of the main apartment that's
correct and the main apartment is
penthouse five in the eastern columbia
building right
no the well
depends on what the main apartment's
penthouse three generally when we say
main apartment penthouse five was where
you had your closet
the downstairs was kind of like uh had
some of my painting studio set up and a
reception area upstairs was the closet
mezzanine
office was in between all right so it's
your testimony that defendant's exhibit
512 reflects damage to the penthouse
penthouse 5 that occurred during the
december 15th 2015 incident right i'm
just not sure from which incident this
is a picture of since i'm only looking
at even though our counselor
was asking you questions about december
15 2015 and then admitted this test this
picture into evidence
again in relation to that incident sorry
go ahead in relation to that incident on
december 15 2015.
this exhibit defendant's exhibit you are
the defendant
number 512 was admitted into evidence in
this court you testified that this was
the result of damage that occurred on
december 15 2015. yes or no
i just need to orient myself because i'm
just looking at a picture of a partial
picture of
you looked at your testimony i you
pointed me towards the page and then
asked me a question i haven't actually
reviewed it i don't know if this was
submitted in relation to that incident
let's pull up
let's actually leave up defendants 512
and please pull up defendants exhibit
725
which is already in evidence thank you
and redacted form your honor all right
thank you you can publish just side by
side
you've seen this photograph as well
right i have
on the third day of your direct
testimony you testified that this
photograph reflected spilled wine in
penthouse 5 on may 21st 2016. didn't you
again i don't know because i'm looking
at a partial picture of a floor so
unless you've removed the metadata
you've covered up we could then tell if
you i didn't cover it up you're on it
could we unredact ourselves so we could
get contacts that's how it's in evidence
that's how it's in evidence next
question the metadata next to it is so
this is heard
there is no question pending and i would
appreciate it if you wouldn't be making
argument to the jury sorry i think you
would ask me about it
no i didn't ask you about anything
let's look at your direct testimony from
the third day
yes ma'am
thank you
thank you
let's turn to page 4750
in day 17 transcript
uh sorry four seven five zero
specifically line 16.
do you see where miss bradahoff asked
you to describe for the jury what took
place on may 21st 2016. i see that
and do you see that your testimony
is reflected about may 21 2015
yes follows okay yes
now let's turn to page 4804
at line 14
4804.
starting at line 14 yes
through 4805 line 4.
going to what line
line four at four eight
zero five
do you see that you're testifying the
defendant's exhibit 725 which is
reflected on the right side reflects
spilled wine on the floor in penthouse
5. that's correct okay and defendants
exhibit 512 and 725 seem to be different
versions of the same picture don't they
that's correct okay so which is it which
one was taken on december 15 2015
or may 21
first 2016.
if you remove the redact metadata you
can find out
it's right there or if you're telling
the truth you would know
recognize a portion of a of spilled wine
on a floor and i'm supposed to know off
the top of my head when you live through
five years of this stuff i don't think
so that's not how that works okay
thank you tom
ms heard at the beginning of your
cross-examination listen may we approach
yes
all right ladies and gentlemen the
gallery i would ask that there would be
no words or no phrases no words
no sounds at all coming from you if i
hear one more sound i will clear the
gallery and we will continue this
testimony without anybody in the
courtroom understood good all right your
next question
ms heard at the beginning of your
cross-examination last week i showed you
an audio where you told mr depp to tell
the jury
tell the judge tell the world that he is
a victim of domestic abuse do you
remember that that's correct you
testified you found it hard to believe
that mr depp would tell the world that
he's a victim of domestic abuse
didn't you
i said i find it hard to believe that he
would do that knowing that he himself
had beat me up for five years but he has
told the world that he's your victim of
domestic abuse hasn't he
well he started to say that only
recently he didn't make that claim up
until very recently so when we signed
our divorce agreement and we signed a
statement saying that neither party had
ever said false claims for financial
gain
it was relevant and important to me
because i was the only one making the
accusations i was the only one making
those claims he wasn't doing that at the
time and he signed his name to it
you didn't expect as many people to show
up and testify on his behalf
that did did you
incorrect
when you told this jury under oath that
you never assaulted
actually struck that sorry um when you
told this jury under oath that you
punched mr depp because you thought of
mr deb pushing kate moss down the stairs
you didn't expect miss moss to agree to
testify that that never happened did you
incorrect i know how many people will
come out of the woodwork to be in
support of johnny so you think this mom
needs to come out of the woodwork to
testify for mr depp
everybody who is around in the 90s and
the early aughts knew that rumor i had
heard that rumor from multiple people of
course that's what flashed through my
head when my violent husband not only
swung for me but all of a sudden swung
for my sister of course i thought of
that i did not expect her to show up or
not expect her to show up it didn't
matter it doesn't change what i believed
at the time when we were on the stairs
and i thought he was going to kill my
sister by pushing her down the stairs
you told this jury under oath and mr
duck was aggressive and trashed a
trailer in hicksville you didn't expect
the manager of the hicksville property
morgan knight to come forward and
testify that that wasn't true did you
incorrect i've already been through
trials with this man i know how many
people will come out in support of him
when you told this jury under oath that
you had no idea that the paparazzi would
be at the courthouse on may 27 2016. you
didn't expect a tmz employee to show up
to testify that tmz had been alerted
that you would be at the courthouse and
knew exactly which side of your face to
take a picture of did you
i know how many people will come out and
say whatever for him that's his power
that's why i wrote the op-ed is i was
speaking to that phenomenon how many
people will come out in support of him
and will fall to his power he is a very
powerful man and people love currying
favor we're powerful men correct and i
know that firsthand jail time for
committing perjury
excuse me
i didn't i didn't hear your questions
miss vasquez if you do
please just repeat the question i didn't
hear you curry favor and commit perjury
in this courtroom
i have a powerful man i have seen people
do this time and time again that's why i
wrote the op-ed you didn't expect ben
king the house manager in australia to
show up from england he flew from
england to testify that mr duff's
fingertip was found exactly where he
said it would be did you
i have never heard johnny testify to
knowing where his finger was or really
frankly
making a claim that he knew where it was
when it was found
i've never heard johnny claim that you
didn't exactly know why johnny has never
heard he said that it's heard
and i think the jury misheard there's no
question pending
you didn't expect keenan wyatt mr
death's longtime sound technician to
show up and testify that mr depp is not
being fed lines through his earpieces
but instead music did you
not that it matters much but of course
of course i did i i know how his
employees treat him so you probably his
team treats him of course i expected
that okay so you probably expected
either bruce to come and testify for mr
deb right
um i'm not sure i thought about that
yeah but you didn't expect mr bruce to
weep
to weep for mr depp
after what you've put him through and so
many others with your life i'm relate to
i relate to isaac because he and i are
the only ones who pride on this stance
nothing all right
uh redirect
thank you your honor miss heard if if mr
baroosh felt misled who misled him
johnny and i don't blame him i don't
blame him from crying this is horrible
miss vasquez has suggested that you
faked bruises on your face is that true
absolutely not i didn't need to
did you ever fake an injury caused by mr
debt
no is any of the evidence of your
injuries that has been put to the jury
in this trial fake
no absolutely not
and to the extent that there may be some
confusion over when a picture of spilled
wine was taken why might that be
objections lack of foundation over rule
because there's so many incidents of
violence there are so
there's so many pictures there's so much
evidence most people don't have this
kind of evidence for years five
years and when i was saying that to
johnny on the phone in that recording i
was saying for years this has been going
on and i have pictures we have text we
have everything
normally you don't get this amount of
evidence that's what i was pointing out
to johnny would be crazy to try to
challenge this in this way
it's crazy it's easy to to not know the
context of a picture of spilled wine
because there are so many more important
details pictures and also
so much i didn't photograph so much i
didn't have the presence actually
non-responsive
i'll sustain the objection next question
did mr depp abuse you physically
yes
verbally
yes
emotionally yes
psychologically
yes
how did the threats
that mr depp made against you
individually years ago
resemble what you have endured as a
result of the death waldman statements
beyond the scope across your honor oh
world
johnny
promised me
promised me
he would ruin me
that he'd ruin my career
he'd take my life from me death was the
only way out and if i got out this is
what he'd do to me he'd make me think of
him every single day he promised me
global humiliation you saw those texts
he
what he couldn't do
the work of one individual meaning
johnny when he was
inviting a disgruntled employee over for
a spot of purple to fix my flabby ass up
that revenge that he sought back then
was just what he could do as an
individual calling the studio to get me
fired trying to block him
how did those
things that you just testified to that
mr depp did how did those resemble what
happened to you after the dep waldman
counter claim statements were made
well those are
on her lack of foundation
she's
overruled thank you thank you your honor
those are just an echo
of what
i'm living through today it's like what
i'm living in right now what you see in
this courtroom is an echo this courtroom
and the other courtroom he dragged me
into to do the same thing again
that's just an echo of the violence and
the abuse that i suffered within our
relationship
the campaigns to have me fired that
blocking me to try to ruin my career the
threats he's made to humiliate me
globally
are being lived out in real time in
front of you ladies and gentlemen for
the past six weeks and for the whole
world since our cameras here
no further questions thank you so much
amber all right let's hear you can have
a seat next to your attorneys
if i could have the attorney's approach
all right your next witness your honor
the counter claimant amber heard rests
all right thank you man
all right ladies and gentlemen you have
heard all the evidence you're going to
hear in this matter what i propose doing
is to go ahead and give you the rest of
the afternoon off so you can have a good
restful afternoon and evening and we
will do closing arguments tomorrow
morning at 9am and then the case will be
submitted to you for deliberations just
to give you a little logistics of how
that will go tomorrow
i won't give you a time limit as far as
how long you can deliberate in the
afternoon into the evening
i will tell you within reason i will
tell you i do not serve dinner so keep
that in mind okay you will not be
deliberating on saturday or sunday or
monday because monday is a holiday i
would like to have you back here tuesday
morning
at least by nine o'clock if you want to
come earlier that's up to you you can
decide as a group if you want to come
earlier than nine o'clock but you have
to be here at least by nine o'clock just
to resume your deliberations again
and again on tuesday night and if you
have to go to wednesday or thursday that
the time that when you take your breaks
is up to you as long as you take them uh
together as far as not having any
deliberations unless all of the jurors
are in the room at the same time when
you take your lunches up to you and then
again in the evening within reason i'll
let you go as long as you'd like to go
okay
so have a good evening and we'll see you
tomorrow morning okay do not discuss the
case with anybody don't do the outside
research
all right
we'll go ahead and take a
modified lunch recess just until 12 50.
we'll come back at 12 50. we just have a
few jury instructions left we have to do
make sure we get the verdict form taken
care of i want you to review the laptop
that we have mocked up and make sure
everybody agrees what's on it
and also i want you to look through all
your exhibits and make sure we're on the
same page before you leave i'll make
sure you have copies of the jury
instructions in the order that i'm going
to read them and you should be able to
prepare for your closing arguments for
tomorrow okay
all right we'll see at 12 50 then
my bro can get used to this
okay
next
thank you
hey howdy
i have a feeling you will see each other
again
[Applause]
um
four down
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
let's go ahead and start with jury
instructions since they're almost all
done
that would be helpful
okay
i already
have them in a potential order but let's
go ahead and go through them one thing
i'll do for the record first plaintiff's
287 which is the same as defendant 780 t
um is a corrupted file that we received
from both of you i guess is corrupted on
both of them
and nobody seems to be able
to do anything about it
so i think it might just be that it's in
evidence however it's not going to go
back to the jury because it's corrupted
okay does everybody agree to that yes
your honor thank you it's just an
eastern columbia building video so
that's fine that's just yeah just it's
corrupt
[Music]
okay do you have more exhibits to give
good let's get jamie here
all right
all right so these
you want to get your list jamie make
sure
go ahead all right it's uh defendants
393
821
857
857 a
883
uh one eight five nine
nineteen oh five
make sure that's nothing that's the
second page of that
ten fifty 10.50
this seems to be a longer one hold on
and i think that is it correct
all right are you missing any other
exhibits
you're on our
approach yes you have something okay
today let's go ahead and get those
all right so these were the two through
oh
all right so we have
okay i think i i think this one's theirs
all right so i have plaintiff's exhibit
13 16 and 13 17.
1301 does anybody have 1301
plaintiffs 1301
an instagram post
we'll get it your honor
seven eleven a and seven eleven b the
one without the metadata and one with
the metadata showing it was the same
pictures but it showed the method i
believe that was seven twelve a and
seven twelve and seven thirteen a yes
seven i don't have those well we just
don't have 7 12 and 7 13 a understood
okay
can i get them now
i'm trying to get all the exhibits
together right now so we have them all
together so we can review them
and then the other one is
120d is not in evidence but it's on
their list as in evidence
120d
isn't david yes
so 120d was listed as you had it as an
evidence but we do not have it in
evidence
all right
is that every all the pieces of evidence
excellent
that's good
good okay so we are very close to
getting all that i just wanted i don't
want to leave here until we have every
piece of evidence with jamie and
everybody has reviewed it so we don't
have to review that tomorrow
and and waste time with that okay
all right so
now i think we can do jury instructions
correct
all right
let me just go over the ones that we had
a few issues with
um at the first one i'm going to go over
is the
self-defense
the two there's two uh that would be
number 28 and 29 correct and i took
those under advisement um do you still
have an objection to the self-defense
all right
so what what evidence
do we have in trial that would would
allow to have this
these two jury instructions
share your honor so i think the evidence
there's evidence in the record showing
that um you know mr waldman was mr
depp's agent that uh you know he was
retained in connection with the uk
litigation and with this litigation
um there's evidence that he engaged with
third parties in that capacity that he
meant the daily mail of mr depp and that
he believed mr depp's version of events
and so i think all of that i think is is
relevant evidence to a
self-defense that mr waldman made those
statements in self-defense
on behalf of mr depp
all right so you're saying if
if agency is found if agency is found
we believe they're inappropriate your
honor first of all we have not been able
to locate case law but um
we found one from 18 what was it 18 16
187 and i know i had seen one um we said
it was a reversible error if you didn't
give the self-defense one so
well i
i know we had taken a look at one a
while back i think but i don't have a
case site for you i think it's a
question of law as to whether it applies
so
at a minimum i think we should
figure that out i guess but the reason
we don't think it should apply
um is these were statements that are
made that were made by mr waldman
in 2020
i guess it was before miss heard's
counter claim so
if he's saying that he goes to the op ed
i think understood so if he's saying
that it's
this lawsuit was a statement
in response to the off the op-ed
statements that were made a year and a
half later by mr waldman and it doesn't
i mean again your honor that the key
words are fairly and reasonably so
obviously both sides are going to argue
defamatory implication and what did the
op-ed really mean and it did it say
these things but saying
even under their theory two years ago i
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse
to say that then it's fair for mr
waldman a year and a half later to make
public statements that amber and her
friends roughed up the place and spilled
the little wine what you know all the
things that he said in those statements
that's not fairly and reasonably miss
herd
responded fairly and reasonably to mr
depp's
case but through her counter claim the
parties can speak to each other in the
courtroom here but the saying that if
someone makes a statement in an op-ed
that then you can go and launch do
whatever you want for
two years say whatever you want and
obviously there's only three statements
that comprise the counter claim but as
the evidence is shown it was part of a
pattern by mr waldman it was i mean it's
the opposite of proportionate it's the
opposite of fair and reasonable response
okay mr depp's opportunity for a fair
and reasonable response well we don't
believe it was either but
he had the opportunity to file a lawsuit
in this court right um to have mr
waldman be his attack dog and to say
anything mr waldman then says as his
attack dog is somehow fair and
reasonable and entitled to the privilege
is inappropriate and i do think that
before your honor gives it we need to
confirm whether it's a question of law
okay
your honor
mr ron moore noted that this lawsuit was
a response to the op-ed but i think
there could be multiple statements in
response to the op-ed so that
i think that's not dispositive of
anything and the statements were clearly
a direct response to to mishearn's
allegations on their face and whether
those whether those whether that
response was fair and reasonable it's a
jury question
i i don't what what do you say is the
matter of law the privilege of
self-defense is a matter of law
i think it could be whether it applies
okay
well i think i don't think it's a matter
of law i think it's whether or not if
there is any evidence that a jury could
find
it being protective speech not the
weight of the evidence but if there is
any evidence and i don't think it's my
my role to weigh that evidence as far as
how long it was made afterwards
um
i i think i think it is your honor i
mean it can't be the case that anytime
there's an alleged death this is why
this doesn't come up often because this
isn't this just isn't given if this if
this if it were appropriate here every
time
there's a defamation case
this would be a a
an instruction even the person who's the
defendant in the case
all i said i was i was responding to
something that was said before so all
your evidence that you say goes to the
jury are these the statements that's why
this should be given
that he made the statements that's the
only evidence
well i think i
you gave me evidence of agency but
that's just agency do you have any
evidence that of self-defense that this
was that he actually said these
statements because of what she said well
i think there's circumstantial evidence
at least that he's he's so it's agency
he's an attorney who's retained in
connection with this litigation of the
uk litigation that doesn't automatically
give you self-defense though a privilege
of self-defense
and that's
you have to make them i have to have
some evidence
that the statements were made in
response to the direct accusations of
misheard
some
on their face they appear to be a direct
response not the statements themselves
but is there any other evidence
but the statements fairly arose in
response to miss heard's accusation
didn't anybody testified that they
that he made these statements in
response to her
op-ed
no
not that i'm aware of your honor all
right
your honor just one small point there
there's no requirement that it be in
response to the op-ed in particular the
question for self-defense to apply is
simply whether it's made in response to
an allegation against mr depp and mr
walden's evidence is clear i think that
he was responding to allegations against
mr depp and he believed those
allegations to be false there was
extensive evidence in the record on that
in fact i think
that he was responding to so if it's not
the op-ed then then we're really in
murky ground if he says well i was
responding to what she said in 2016
that's
well
what mr munoz is saying is that you take
it as a separate case
um
[Music]
you take it as a as a separate case
their claim and then your counter claims
so your counter claim is a separate
standalone case
right
oh
okay so the standalone case doesn't
your your claim doesn't deal with the
op-ed so they're saying in defense of
your case
that's why this comes in
but
he couldn't have made it he couldn't
have made the statements in defense of
our case because these are the basis for
our case so what he had been what was he
responding to if it wasn't the op-ed and
if it's not the op-ed then we're really
in murky ground because there's no plus
you're on our couple points there was no
there's to your point there's been no
testimony that he made these in
self-defense to anything
to that the defense
doesn't apply
it and this is um
well it doesn't this is under the
haycocks case 1958 it doesn't apply if
we prove malice so it has to be made in
good faith and without malice so it's co
co extends i could bring the case up if
you want you're on it it's it's so if
the malice inquiry incorporates this
this is the um
let's see
200 virginia 212
haycocks versus wilcox done
and it looks like on page eight
uh sorry 231
um they're discussing a massachusetts
case
and
that says um
statements made in an honest endeavor to
vindicate one's character to protect
one's interest are usually regarded as
qualifiedly privileged even though
they're false if they are made in good
faith and without malice
so the malice inquiry takes care of this
and
in addition i don't i don't think i need
to remind the court but for the record
you know
mr waldman was not allowed to answer any
questions about this so to say well you
know he could have been making it in
defense of something they could let him
answer questions and get that evidence
on the record they can't say well he
could have been making it in defense to
something now
and and when i say
just looking at at your case i
you you're you're
you're claiming these alleged defamation
um
the three we have allegations well
they're saying in response that they
made them because of something she said
that maybe is not the op-ed
but then there's no evidence of what
that is she responds she was sued she
said she said the op she said 2016 when
she made her
then
2018 she
has the op-ed that have
you know a couple words that they're
trying to turn into what we've seen for
the last six weeks and then she
responded to the lawsuit okay so
it can't be the case that by trying to
defend yourself in a lawsuit that was
brought against you if it's not the
op-ed then it's got to be her statements
in the lawsuit that somehow trying to
defend yourself through judicially
immune statements in a lawsuit entitles
someone else to go out and say whatever
they want and then try to veil
themselves in the privilege the council
from has heard made a point of of
making clear that there was extensive
allegations about mr depp circulating
they repeatedly brought up the uk action
which was in fact the context in which i
believe these statements were made based
on the date it was very close in time to
the uk action they brought up the dan
wooten article
um these allocations date back to 2016.
these allegations are out there and
there's a jury from which there's
evidence excuse me from which the jury
could find that mr waldman was acting in
defense of mr tap
we're not acting in defense against miss
heard's accusations so what are ms
hurd's accusations that would be defense
that are in evidence
you're honored the out the there has
been extensive evidence of the
accusations against mr depp going back
in 2016.
for example the dan wooten article that
they that they raised in evidence
prior to the op-ed um which which
included the word wife beater um and it
was essentially you know but it has to
be that's not his heart statement
statement
i don't believe that's correct your
honor it doesn't have to be against ms
heard's accusations it is it is correct
that that would be crazy your honor if
they get a jury instruction because he
was responsible
yeah i mean again the number of
allegations made by ms hurt it's been
very well well documented in this case
you have you have the op-ed and it
doesn't have to be just it doesn't have
to be any one particular allocation but
you have the op-ed you have the people
magazine article you have the
republication of her statements through
the through the wife peter and the dan
newton article you have the fact that
she was giving testimony in the uk
action
um about these issues well
well then would you agree that actual
malice you don't get the self-defense if
there's actual malice in his statements
if the jury finds actual malice then you
don't
if the jury finds actual malice then
it's not protected that may obviate the
privilege but that doesn't mean that the
privilege is not applicable or a valid
but the only way they can find in this
case is if there is actual malice this
goes back to their defense slap defense
as well
the only way they find defamatory
statements in this case is if there's
actual malice and that's unique to this
case i understand that
but so if they find actual mouse
inflammatory statements you don't have
protected speech privilege
and if there's no actual mouse they win
yes correct the same with this that's
why we're not giving a jury instruction
on the slap defense because there's no
basis for it
yeah
i mean
if the if the instruction is not being
given on the understanding that it's
essentially moot um
which i i agree i think what's what
happened with the slap defense as well
we found out after we went down that
legal road we found out that was moot as
well
okay
so do you want me to deny it or withdraw
it i'll do either one uh if you don't
mind denying you're not okay i'll deny
that's
instruction 28 and 29.
put that deny stack
all right next one i have is the
republication
one um
okay
so
[Music]
i see both of them
dueling a
for
paragraph
republication yes sir
and um
i understand last time we spoke that you
added you must determine whether any
content that was added constitutes
a republication
and you just would rather have just the
three sentences as yours for
republication is that correct correct
your honor um that didn't no well you
must find that she read
or do you want to add that
into it i'm not sure i'm just not sure
how i'm reading it i i think i think you
know i don't need to put words in their
mouth i think we want the whole thing at
the top right
um
and they just want the one sentence at
the bottom
okay that's correct and
your honor we
talked about not going backwards we went
over this on friday your honor said that
um on page 92 of the attraction i don't
have a problem with the republished jury
instruction i just think it has to be
accurate with adding a language and that
language
was on page 89
you said but you also have to say but
adding content to it may establish
republication so that's what we did in
this in the sentence that starts with
merely linking right it did say merely
linking to an article does not amount to
republication period and then we added
directly from the transit but adding
content to it may establish
republication so that now they've now
they're going backwards they just want
you to strike the whole thing except in
the first sentence and that's different
from your honor's ruling
on friday and also doesn't fully capture
no it doesn't capture the whole
legal argument
if i may just just uh make our our
argument for the record here in your
honor you did on friday but if you want
to do it again that's fine okay just
very quickly so i i think the issue with
republication is whether it reaches a
new audience which is um what people
that's there what we propose
it's included in their instruction and
that is
basically the full extent of our
proposed instruction and we believe it
should be limited to that okay um
lokova is a case that they've repeatedly
cited in support of this republication
issue and that's the case where
there was a defamatory new york times
article that was hyperlinked in a more
recent new york times article and the
court said that that's
not directed at a new audience it's the
same party tweeting to the same audience
so there's no republication and that's
not the case here where ms hurd has
retweeted a washington post article so
that you know miss heard's article miss
her's audience on twitter
is different than the washington post
but if she just retweeted a hyperlink
that's different but in this context and
that's why i took the motion strike
under advisement once i got it there was
more content to it and that's why i'm
putting it in the jury instruction
because it is accurate that hyperlink
alone is not enough to reach new
audience but i'm willing to what i think
would also add to it though is after you
must determine whether any content that
was added constitutes republication
and
let's see i would say then
you must determine whether any added
content republish the op-ed to a new
audience i could say it that way
or
i could say but adding content to a
linked article may constitute republican
you must determine whether any added
content was intended to reach a new
audience you find it was intended to
reach a new audience it constitutes a
republication i could say that
add that to the end of that paragraph i
think that i think i think that's fine
if
that's the court's inclination do you
have any objection to that
i'm just
i'm i'm thinking sorry i'm okay
one more time yeah
sure okay
um
let's see
all right let me see if i can
incorporate into it okay so merely
linking to an article does not amount to
replication
but adding content to a linked article
may constitute republication you must
determine
whether any added content was intended
to reach a new audience if you find it
was intended to reach a new audience it
constitutes a republication
i think we would prefer just to say just
that first sentence merely linking to an
article does not amount to republican
but adding content to a linked article
may establish republication period well
that's what you already had this is no
no because we had the you must determine
whether any added content that was added
constitutes a republican i think it'd be
better to just delete the last two
sentences than to add the sentence at
the end
your honor i think i just want i just
want to note i don't think that adding
content is is a requirement for
republication i mean we've found a
number of cases that when somebody
repeats a defamatory statement they're
as liable as the original defamer
we're not in fact we're not going
backwards so either it's his language or
my language what do you want i prefer
the course language all right i'm gonna
put my cards on okay
um
do you want us to do the revisions
because if you do it we may have to just
get one one more time from you okay um
we're happy to or can see me can you do
it
okay
you got you gave him to gave him into
the word format we did all right can you
do that here the only other thing i
would notice i think the word
retransmitted in the second line is
misspelled
in the second line okay all right we'll
take care of that
but adding content just do it
adding content yeah just like this one
right here
two and then just get rid of all of this
and add this instead
all right and we'll clean it up
okay we'll get that done
all right takes care of that one next
one
it's i think instruction ff
um defamatory meaning consider the
publication as a whole and we have
dueling answers here and the defendant
just has op-ed in it
the plaintiff just has it is plain which
i mean
it does say that it means you may not
seize any word phrase or image
so it would appear that so it could
apply to both of them in that context
the problem your honor is that
we believe that because
the counterclaim statements that the
jury will be presented with
are
redacted so the statements are in
isolation that there's a risk that as
they're phrasing it the jury may read
the phrase you must read the statements
and context as a whole
to say well we can't do that so
therefore there's no liability
we think because it's it's
it's impossible
to read those statements in the context
of the whole piece
and so
so that's number one number two um the
the op-ed was all amber statements so
the whole instance of her words the the
counter claim statements were mr
waldman's quotes in another article that
we don't believe
you know that's not an evidence there's
no point arguing about that other than
you just have these one you know
one or two sentences from mr waldman
um
so we believe that the the jury's going
to be confused if we give their
instruction and say we cannot read it as
a whole so therefore we can't um
you know we can't follow the jury
instruction okay
i can see your point with that yes sir i
don't think there's anything in the
there i mean there's a lot of
instructions here i don't think there's
anything that would indicate they can't
find a liability if they're not able to
take
statements in their their proper context
in the context of the entire article um
just thought it would be more
appropriately phrased to be mutual
as opposed to obviously applying only to
one party
well because yours says you must read
the statements which is
true but you also can take the content
in a context as a whole but there's you
can take the context of the op-ed as a
whole which is accurate
um i what i could do if you want i could
keep the op-ed up top for
their
their claim and then for your claim
determining whether any of the
statements
attributed mr waldman are false and and
defamatory you must read the statements
i could keep that in there as a second
paragraph
that way you that way they can't just
pull out which because it's accurate law
also that it just can't fill out the
word hoax and say okay this whole
statement agreed okay that's fine
okay
that's that's fine and concept i guess i
would ask if jerome does that to add a
clause saying disregarding any
redactions on
well it says the statements themselves
statements and statements and theirs you
must read the statements in context as a
whole right
so
i i think
i mean could we say in determining
whether any of mr waldman's statements
or whatever are false and defamatory
you must read
the text of those statements as a whole
the text of those statements in context
as a whole or something um that's kind
of you must read the statement in
context as a whole you must read can we
say you must read those statements in
context you must read those because i i
statements in context that it's
impossible for them to any problem with
just putting those instead of the uh i
don't think we have a problem okay in
determining whether any of the
statements attributed to mr waldman are
faltered and defamatory you must read
those statements in context as a whole
this means you may not seize on any one
word phrase or image or consider only
one particular statement phrase or
passage in isolation does that sound
correct yes all right we'll add that as
a second paragraph keep sammy
busy
takes care of that
all right the next one i
have is the objections and assertions of
privilege
which
third 32. i'm sorry it's a depth 32.
it's a new
a new instruction
um oh oh yeah right right right one at
the end this is the new one do you have
the objection we do
yeah okay um
the objection your honor is that
the
objections made
during by counsel during the course of
trial
we have no problem with something on
that but instructions that what they're
trying to do is to direct the jury how
to
what inference to draw from mr waldman's
instructions not to answer well and well
the only legal inference they can draw
they can't draw any inferences from that
exactly and that's my point as well
that's what this says you may not uh
draw any inferences from the fact that
objection was made
yeah but saying some sometimes attorneys
stated objections during the course of
this trial and instructed a witness no
right
and instructed a witness not to answer a
question objections and instructions to
witnesses are not evidence and you may
not consider them in reaching your
verdict nor are you to draw any
information so
why do they need to be told this i mean
i think this is i think this risks
because well because to be to be
fair the depositions you wanted to keep
in all those objections when we usually
would take them out but you wanted to
keep them in so i want to make sure the
jury doesn't have any
improper inferences
from leaving those objections in you
want to leave them in because show that
hey i asked the questions they weren't
answered fine
but you can't infer from that oh well
they're hiding something then or it's
attorney client
understood i mean just like you can't
infer when someone takes the fifth in a
criminal case i get i get that right
which i would give an instruction of
course i know i understand that but i
think that the i think that the
the jury
is entitled to draw their own
conclusions and not inferences i'm not
entitled infer anything from that but i
just think that this risks confusing the
jury and
getting them to getting
the jury to think
if they stand up in closing and say they
haven't presented any evidence
that mr waldman was doing this then
that's using
this instruction as a sword
if they get up there and say they
haven't
do you understand what i'm saying they
haven't
proven that mr waldman was acting as his
attorney they haven't proven that mr
waldman was authorized to make the
statements then then and then they rely
on this to hide behind that
and we're not allowed and i'm not saying
that we will but i'm not going to say
you heard him instruct him not to answer
and that's you should infer that he was
acting as his agent i know i'm not going
to say that but if they're going to
argue in closing
the converse of that then that's not
that's prejudicial and that's
what makes this interference right yes
sir
this is just an accurate statement of
law they chose to play about 30 minutes
if mr baldwin being instructed not to
answer without this instruction that's
prejudicial
all right and it would also be
prejudicial if they're allowed in
closing to
say that we haven't presented evidence
of
anything about the parameters of mr
waldman and depp's relationship that's
that that doesn't follow from this
instruction this instruction is simply
saying that the jury is not to draw any
inferences from the objections and
instructions inserted by council they
can consider the evidence they could
consider whether evidence was presented
or not
the the instructions
and objections are irrelevant to that
question
now all right i understand your
your objections but it is an accurate
phrasing of the law
and uh i want to make sure that the
inferences aren't taken
against an attorney-client privilege
okay um
can you deny it over our you got it um
i mean no i can grant it over your
objection it's hard okay
yes sorry um
can we get some
direction for the arguments that they're
allowed to make on closing on that your
honor because i don't think that's
appropriate for them to point to a lack
of evidence when they didn't allow mr
waldman to testify
pointing out that instructions are not
evidence it's not to say there's no
connection here between these issues
rather no i i i'm not going to do that
so we're going to do
depth 32
i just need to clean up the top part of
it
okay
all right
over objection
the offered
all right then i have instruction jj
which is is the model
right so why would i not give the model
we believe you should i think
i think the only
um
looks like the only substantial
difference is that they and rather than
saying this
as it's written it says clear and
convincing evidence that mr waldman's
statements
it's confusing and misleading to say
that mr
if you found by clear and convincing
evidence that mr waldman's statements
were made by mr depp that we already
have a principal agent instruction right
if they find principal or agent i mean
that would be the only basis for it
well first of all your honor if if i if
if liability is entirely
vicarious which i think is the position
of of the um
counterclaim plaintiff in this case
i don't think there's any evidence of
direct liability if liability is
entirely vicarious then i don't think
there's a basis for punitive damages
instruction at all against mr deb
because vicarious liability generally
doesn't result in punitive damages as to
the principle
um uh
punitive damages are only applied where
where the
person against which punitive damages
are being assessed actually engaged in
conduct that it was wrongful uh and
that's not the way they've pled and
sought to prove their case
um i think that's the that's the first
so the question okay
they're saying you're not entitled to a
permanent punitive damages instruction
well i i disagree with that and there's
i don't
there's no case law that they've cited
in here on that and i think that's going
backwards that's an argument that okay
and i i just think that mr waldman's
statements
were made by mr deaf i mean i'd be okay
with something that said that mr waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made
statements with knowledge i'd be okay
with that
did you is that okay
i think we would maintain our objection
on that um
on the basis previously asserted your
honor and then what's the other
one
i'm sorry could i have counsel's
language again one more time sure yeah
if you have found by clear and
convincing evidence
that mr waldman comma while acting as an
agent for mr depp comma made the
statements with knowledge that they were
false or so recklessly
i think it's so reckless
there's a typo there sorry
um
we'd be okay with that
yeah i mean we we do maintain the same
objection you're under the principal
liability and we do have case law for
for that process overrule that objection
we'll go ahead and
can you type that up real quick for me
sure and get that to me if you email it
to sami we can print it out yep okay
you're in charge of that one
okay
all right
that's fine
i think that was it correct as far as i
think it was
other than the verdict
perfect let's go to the verdict
foreign
all right i think with the verdict form
it was just
um
the first page
am i correct with that
in the p and the punitive damages
and well the piano damage you didn't
have a response right do we have
i think there was just there was a
comment in what we got from them that we
changed um
okay
all right well in the
oh thank you
all right uh the i think it was in 1a
the statement was about mr depp i think
the plaintiff wanted that out because we
already have the statement has a
defamatory implication about mr depp and
the defamatory implication was designed
intended by ms hurt
which i think is
if you look at the
um i think it should track the finding
instruction um
um
which is
very instruction c
for the jury instructions and that's
what the verdict form does okay let me
take a look
and that was c okay yeah
okay
so the way it's been written tracks the
following
instruction yeah we don't have a strong
objection here your honor i thought it
was maybe cumulative but um it does
match the finding instruction which
would be clear to the jury so we'll keep
that in that's fine and then the
punitive
it's the
last to all of that are you through all
those uh we'll withdraw that your honor
their proposed language is fine right so
the verdict forms as written are the
verdict forms good to go correct no i
well
i'm sorry did they did you withdraw did
they withdraw the punitive damages okay
sorry
so we're good with the verdict forms
what i have is the verdict forms correct
uh your honor um i i think yes but i do
just want to make sure and i understand
we don't go back but i just want to make
sure that for the record
we do maintain that the
verdict form should state that um the
defamatory implication was false and not
that the statement was false because
under the pendleton case that can you
know a facially true statement can still
have a false defamatory indication and i
think we had that other record on friday
but thanks for holding it again it's
fine all right so verdict forms are good
did you print out the other
side
no you can print it out that's how yeah
so
which ones are we missing then we're
missing
which jury instructions
you're working on two of them right
32 and ff and you have one jury
instruction for me right
yes they're editing it right now on it's
jj
okay jj is coming in
and
did you do the other one yet or no
here
could you guys do
michelle or
could you on depth 32 could you take off
disputed and send that to us too yes
thank you
and that would just leave us we'll get
those to print out and then i'll tell
you the order that i'm going to do them
while i'm doing that i do have the um
the laptop
if both sides would like to
look at the jury evidence on these um
they're gonna
they'll stay up here at the at the bench
but it
all we did
was we
put two files on here there's there's no
password for it as soon as you open up
it doesn't have any internet and there's
just two files
one's plaintiff one's defended they just
click on those two and then they can
watch all the audio and the video okay
so if you want to take a look and make
sure it's it's been downloaded to
everything that we put on on our website
which is all the evidence we didn't
receive any new evidence today for audio
or video files so that it's everything
on there but if you want to take a look
and make sure that everything is there
you can do that
also all the tangible app exhibits
jb will have except we need to get those
other ones so we can oh you have them
perfect yes um if i may approach i have
okay 1301
okay
and then
uh your honor i just would like some
clarification sure
um
i understand that
exhibit
set defendants exhibit 712 and
defendants exhibit 713
were initially
moved into evidence in redacted format
correct today we
offered them and put them in an
unredacted form so that's the 7 12 a and
7
and then 13
yeah um i believe your honor you should
already have those in unredacted form i
believe that's how they were provided to
you
down here i believe so i i will i will
yes so i believe though you should
actually have those in unredacted form
from defendants
all right
um
we have a few binders down here yes i
would i think they would be in the
binders that's correct
7
12 and 7 13.
yes
that would make jamie happy since she's
down here
digging through binders
okay perfect all right now we have those
in evidence okay so are we missing any
more from over here or did you find out
about the one that you thought was in
evidence so your honor um defend it i
believe oh excuse me it's plaintiff's
exhibit 120 d i believe actually sammy
and i had a number of back and forth
about this exhibit we i i believe that
defendants council provided a redacted
version of that exhibit to the court but
um based off of our
reading of the transcript that exhibit
was not actually offered into evidence
okay so it's not in evidence
um
okay all right so i just want to make
sure because it was checked off on
somebody's list that it wasn't evidence
and i just wanted to make sure
i don't know but it's not
we're good
and then i i heard the exhibits 7-eleven
a and b i i'm i'm not sure i think that
was wrong it was 7 12 and 7 13.
so we're good all right so jamie are we
missing anything else sam did you print
out the ones that they sent you too
the email did you email sammy the he's
just double checking right now okay okay
we'll get that in a second let me just
put these in the order
all right
get that one without dispute on it
okay sure
it wasn't the one that i gave
all right
just print out two copies so we can
share them the one that sammy printed
off on republication i'm just going to
give you a copy so make sure
they're right okay
and you um you have should receive in
your email soon uh ffjj and 32. okay
so if you put those out too sammy
let's print those out
so you're sending ff
okay
did you take the disputed off the top
thank you
all right let me just get this printed
could somebody
could you print me out another one of aa
i just there's there's a mark on this
one
or at least email it to just email that
one to sammy
something in the paper it just doesn't
look right
got
can you huh them to jamie so she
uh
oh
so
okay
your honor will we um will we be getting
just a paper a paper printout or a um an
electronic copy from the court all i
have is a paper okay so we'll just we
can scan it you can stop it that's fine
if you want to do electronic that's fine
and then will these be posted on the um
not until after i get until after okay i
wasn't sure and then they're red before
closing their red books are closing
all right
i guess we just replaced
thank you
okay
if you want to take a look at that
instruction and make sure it looks okay
before i add it to the stack
you have the actual malice one was that
sent to you
michelle you said the actual malice one
yes okay
oh never mind
sorry jamie
and your honor was it um
i think it's fine is the court does the
court want um to leave the you know herd
c dep seven no sort of things in there
because like otherwise we could hurt you
oh no well yeah the numbers that top can
stay i just don't want i just want to
say disputed
i don't think many of them say okay no
the numbers i i i tell the jurors to
disregard the numbers in the heading
that's better for the record if we keep
it that way
okay so
any are you still reading the
publication okay
your honor can we get sorry to bother um
sammy could we get one more print out of
the actual malice instruction sure thank
you
jamie can we get another actual malice
all right any objection to the
republication then
as
typed
know your honor okay
put that in there
um
hold on is there a typo
nope
it's okay it's okay yep all right
connor i just have a very quick question
regarding closing okay um
does the court have any objection to
us playing very small uh clips of as
long as there are evidence you can play
anything show any picture well that's my
question so okay obviously depositions
were by video many of many witnesses
especially for ms heard do you have any
objection to us playing video
depositions portions if it's not an
evidence it doesn't no of course just
what's in evidence um there's no video
depositions and evidence
oh i see what you mean
okay
so
[Music]
it can only the only thing that can be
played to them is what is in evidence
but their testimony it's witness
testimony well yeah but that would be
like but depositions are witness
testimony that you have during trial
that doesn't go back to the jury as
evidence and deposition video
depositions are the same
that would give more weight to video
depositions than well so my question is
it's a follow-up question to that um
obviously this trial was televised so
there are um videos of witnesses
testifying no none of that comes in okay
no the four walls of this courtroom is
what the jury decides this case in okay
period and just so we don't have a
problem tomorrow also we can't put in
front of the jury
written deposition or just testimony
that's correct only things that are in
evidence but you can show pictures and
evidence you can show video that's in
evidence or audio or audio that's in
evidence oh that's fair game
no display of written transcripts either
no written transcripts just only items
and evidence
and
i was i'm on the same page okay all
right so i'll make sure thank you honor
for clarification and you have two hours
right two hours each and you two people
over here and two people over there is
that what's gonna happen yes
we're gonna split our um we're gonna
split our closing and then one only one
of us will do the rebuttal okay and that
has
and that has to just be on the rebuttal
case correct right on we write that we
have that down right we've gone through
that a few times mr do you have
something on that
yes i just wanted to make sure we were
all on the same page so
plaintiff goes first correct then the
defendant kept playing plaintiff right
they do their defense to your claim and
also they do their their offense to
their claim and then plaintiff plaintiff
gets to do their defense to
them respond only with respect to the
to the rebuttal to their to their
counterpart
and so it goes one two one two
and plaintiff gets two hours they get
two hours uh total does the is
is is it fine if it's not exactly
one hour
that doesn't matter that's of course
your time is just two hours it doesn't
matter how much anybody does thank you
okay if you wanted to shorten that's
about 15 minutes a piece i would want to
short it to two minutes but you know
that's not my take i gave you two hours
i thought we got pretty efficient at the
end well you know it's amazing how that
happens
it's kind of like the physics you know
you make a circle and the people will
fill that circle that's what happens i
made a circle
okay so
let's go ahead and let me just go ahead
and read into the record the order that
i'm going to give the jury instructions
i'll also read the record the the
instructions that were denied
and i will read the instructions that
were withdrawn just so we have a
complete record okay
all right
here we go all right so
for the jury instructions i'll read them
in the following order
number heard i
number three
number ten
one
b as in boy
c as in charlie
d as in delta
e as an echo
that's david david d d
t t
c c c
20
z
as in zebra
t
u
b
as in victor
and jj
those are the ones that will be read to
the jury in that order
okay the ones that were denied
was instruction
22 23
24
cc
n n both isn't nancy
o o
p p
r r
s s
s and sam ss
28 and 29
were the ones that were denied
the ones that were withdrawn
for the record was instruction a
25 26 27
x as an x-ray 31
w
e e
g g
q q
d d d q
l l u e u u
v v
w w
x x
y y z z
a a a
and b b b
all right
so
we will i will get you copies now i'll
get you hand copies of the jury
instructions i'm going to read in that
order so you'll have copies when you
leave here okay and i'll give you copies
of the verdict form as well
and you can have those while you prepare
for your closing arguments
other than that if you could come up to
see jamie after i leave the bench just
to make sure you go through the exhibits
and everybody okay is the exhibit so we
don't do that tomorrow and also if you
can have a look at the laptop with sami
just to make sure all your exhibits are
there that are going to go back to the
jury okay
your honor one quick question um about
closing to make sure we don't have any
issues tomorrow understand um
the jury only sees evidence
yes that they've seen in the trial if
there's
if that evidence is displayed through
like a powerpoint or whatever are
like our headings allowed or do you not
want the jury to see any
any written text or anything other than
just evidence
i mean i've seen powerpoints in in cases
before in med malls where they have
their
other items up there but i think in this
particular case i'd rather just have no
no writing and just have your arguments
orally that's fine i just wanted to yeah
make sure that there wasn't just try to
keep it clean or paraphrasing of
witnesses or anything like that
that sounds
fine with everybody just does anybody
that's fine with me that's a good
question though are you going to have a
powerpoint
probably with evidence okay did you want
me to have the big screen up as well i
think so yeah i think that would be
great okay
okay thank you we'll do that as well and
um starts at nine
starts at nine closings start at nine so
your honor mr natal half has a proffer
still on something oh yeah do you wanna
do that now before yes sir
everybody wants
this will be shorter than the other day
okay
okay um
on
this is for metadata on may 16 and may
17 2022 the defendant attempted to
introduce into evidence photographs from
may 21 2016 that included metadata on
the photographs ms heard testified that
the metadata was included on the photos
by pressing a button on her phone the
metadata demonstrated the pictures were
taken on may 21st 2016 along with the
times they were taken
the exhibits
were defendants exhibits 700 through 726
and our exhibits a through a a
of the proper um tabs n and o of the
proffer are now uh blank as defendants
712 and 713 were admitted
with with the metadata on may 26 2022
mr depp objected to the metadata on the
document stating that the metadata was
hearsay and there was no foundation for
the hearsay the court sustained the
objection on the ground that the
metadata was hearsay and that there was
no foundation and admitted the exhibits
but redacted the metadata
and then separately
we have a proper for us stephen deuters
on may 20th 2022 ms heard moved to
designate
uh certain portions of the deposition
testimony for trial of stephen deuters
who was mr deck's personal assistant
mr deuters testified that he was on the
boston flight and sat in a seat facing
this herd and mr depp he further
testified that the day after the flight
mr depp told him he wanted to quote
smooth whatever issue end quote existed
with miss heard mr depp asked mr deuters
to quote write a text end quote to miss
heard and to say quote whatever she
needs to hear end quote mr deuters then
sent a text message to ms heard about mr
depp stating quote when i told him he
kicked you he cried end quote the
testimony is contained in exhibit a mr
duder's deposition
ms heard moved to admit the text message
into evidence arguing it was not hearsay
under rule 2 colon 803 which provides
for the admission of statements of a
party opponent and his agents ms hurd
argued mr deuters was acting as mr def's
agent when he sent the text and the text
message was therefore not hearsay the
text message is
uh exhibit b to the proper mr def
objected to the text messages hearsay
arguing that although mr peters was mr
depp's employee sending text messages to
ms heard was not within the scope of the
employment the court denied the motion
to admit the text message and testimony
finding that mr deuters was not acting
as mr depp's agent when he sent the text
message and i'll provide i have copies
all right fine we can add it to
the list
we have a box for you
all right
add that
oh sorry it's i think it's more
and this is the other one
all right we'll make them part of the
record thank you sir all right yes miss
myers
thank you your honor um on may 25th 2022
plaintiff intended to call dr kim
collins as an expert witness in forensic
pathology
defendants objected on the basis that dr
collins had not been
designated as a defensive witness
and was designated only to rebut
uh dr jordan which was a defendant's
forensic pathologist who had not been
put up at this trial
dr collins intended to testify
as to whether miss heard's descriptions
of violence and injuries allegedly
sustained by mr depp were consistent
with the photographic evidence at issue
in this trial
she also for incidents where there was
no
photographic evidence she would have
testified as to what injuries she would
have expected to see based off of the
violence that ms heard testified to
um and finally she would have testified
as to her opinion as to the
the
cause or as to mr depp's finger injury
and what she observed consistent which
was similar to what
dr gilbert testified to today
all right thank you any other propers
okay
all right all right so just don't leave
here until you check the laptop and you
check all your evidence and make sure
we get your checkbox on that and
everybody's happy with it okay anything
else for the court
thank you really no thank you thank you
very much thank you okay thank you your
honor we'll see you in the morning
all right